every television fan gets used to the
pain of seeing their favorite series
canceled and we've all seen shows die
because of ratings budget or cash
problems sometimes though the plug gets
pulled for reasons that were totally
avoidable and sometimes even downright
dumb
holy set destruction batman
the 60s batman series starring adam west
isn't anyone's idea of hard-hitting
superhero entertainment but it's a campy
classic and one that might have stayed
on the air longer than two years if the
network hadn't gotten a destructive itch
execs at abc weren't willing to continue
funding batman after its first two
seasons so they decided to sell the
rights to nbc meanwhile nbc wanted to
make sure batman's existing sets and
props were part of the deal
unfortunately during a brief production
hiatus between networks an abc exec had
the sets destroyed the deal died and the
caped crusader hung up his cow
robin hood killed robin hood
jonas armstrong started bbc one's robin
hood decided to vacate the lea role
after the show's third season but
instead of recasting the part with a new
actor the producers opted to simply kill
off the character since they'd already
killed off robin's love made marion that
left the supporting cast to carry the
show you know the one named after a guy
who was dead although robin hood's
writing staff was willing to try a
revamp the network decided there was no
point in continuing
young justice's lousy toy sales
when warner brothers hit pay dirt with
young justice which posted triple digit
ratings increases for its time slot on
cartoon network it seemed safe to assume
they went more than two seasons but the
show was axed after only 46 episodes
prompting outcry and widespread
speculation despite great ratings the
real reason it was cancelled was
frustrating to its fans funding for the
show came from a merchandising tie-in
deal with the unjustice action figures
from mattel but when low sales kill the
toy line the show quickly followed suit
it's unfair when a show that's supposed
to be a 30-minute toy commercial is
actually pretty great but the toys
aren't
kingdom hospital versus csi
few places are scarier than hospitals so
when a horror maestro stephen king made
a deal with abc to write and produce the
haunted medical drama kingdom hospital
it seemed like a perfect fit
sadly the show's sole season was kind of
a mess not on screen where it offered a
solid batch of episodes that earned two
ebby nominations but behind the scenes
where struggles between king and the
network doomed it convinced abc wasn't
promoting kingdom hospital enough king
paid for a print ad campaign only to see
his efforts foiled when execs moved it
to a different time slot king learned
yet again that while ghosts are scary
what's truly terrifying is dealing with
network executives
cast into cancellation hell after buffy
the vampire slayer ended in 2003 fans
flocked to the show's spinoff angel
which was entering its fifth season
after years on the renewal bubble angel
enjoyed a post buffy ratings bump series
creator joss whedon approached wb
network president jordan levin about an
early pickup for season six although
whedon's move wasn't purely a power play
he was looking for extra security for
angel's team who'd endured years of
passing up gigs while waiting for last
minute renewals but levin saw it as an
ultimatum the president pulled the plug
all for the sake of throwing his weight
around although the network later
admitted it was a mistake it was too
late to revive angel
showtime's horror drama penny dreadful
dropped its biggest twist during its
season 3 finale the blessed dark the
series was over while the show is still
having its last rights read let's
investigate the potentially
spoiler-filled mystery of why it had to
end
declining viewership
the last season of penning dreadful was
not a ratings juggernaut clocking in at
number six among showtime's 10 original
shows behind billions and the affair
viewership had dropped over 5 compared
to the previous year while other shows
had fewer viewers penny dreadful's
elaborate settings and special effects
made it far more expensive to produce a
cult following just wasn't enough a
little over half a million people
watched the series finale live
money
like most tv cancellations money was
likely a large factor in showtime's
decision to give penny dreadful the axe
it happened to plenty of other fan
favorite shows over the years firefly
hannibal constantine and dollhouse among
them despite featuring public domain
characters like dracula dr jekyll
frankenstein's monster and dorian gray
the price of bringing this many monsters
to the screen couldn't have been cheap
vanessa ive's departure
despite all the interesting characters
she's met over the past three years
penny dreadful is a tale about vanessa
ives the series ended with her finally
finding peace and while we'll never see
her tangle with the creature or dorian
gray again this sudden ending is how it
was planned
showtime ceo david nevin sent to
entertainment weekly i always knew it
wasn't going to be a really long running
show john logan made that clear coming
in while there were plenty of tales you
could tell without her in this dark
world ives was the focal point of this
show and we couldn't imagine it
continuing without her remember how the
x-files felt without mulder gross
more monsters
without vanessa ives penny dreadful is
pretty much just a bunch of 19th century
ghouls if that's your thing you'll be
seeing a lot more of them soon universal
pictures is launching its own set of
films featuring the most classic of
movie monsters the series began with
dracula untold in 2014 meanwhile the
mummy reboot starring tom cruise is
scheduled for 2017. don't be surprised
if tv executives try bringing frank drak
and the whole monster squad back to
capitalize on hollywood digging them up
from their graves
it was foretold
there are various reasons why penny
dreadful was canceled but we're going to
have to go with show creator john
logan's explanation apparently he knew
this was how the series would end from
the very beginning but the cast found
out halfway through filming season two
in logan's own words penny dreadful was
always intended to go for three years
exactly
so i think we've told our story well and
thank you for all your support and
hanging in there with us all good things
come to an end sorry game of thrones
fans you too will know this sting we're
sure you'll see most of these characters
in other forms soon enough though
as all the major tv networks announced
their pickups and cancellations for the
upcoming season the biggest surprise
came from abc even though the tim allen
show last man standing was the network's
second highest rated comedy abc decided
to drop the sitcom after six seasons why
would they end one of their most
successful shows without warning here
are some of the reasons last man
standing took a fall a major network
shift the last man standing aired on abc
the network didn't actually own the show
the sitcom was produced by 20th century
fox which meant abc had to pay licensing
fees every season this may have factored
into the cancellation because it made
the show more expensive than some of
their other comedies still that may not
be the whole story abc's fresh off the
boat is also produced by 20th century
fox but was renewed for a fourth season
despite lower ratings abc entertainment
president channing dungey said that
axing last man standing was simply a
business decision the network decided to
make friday a night for dramas and once
the scheduling switch was made they felt
last man standing had no place to go the
show shared the night with dr ken which
was also canceled though the ken's young
program netted half as many viewers on
an average night dungey explained the
difference saying last man standing was
a challenging one for me because it was
a steady performer in the ratings but
once we made the decision not to
continue with comedies on fridays that
was where we landed fridays will be all
drama on abc now including once upon a
time and marvel's upcoming inhumans
series
budgeting woes
for a lot of shows season 7 is a year of
contract negotiations last man standing
was no exception tim allen's contract
needed to be renewed which more than
likely meant a pretty big race since the
show made less money for abc because it
was owned by fox and because alan
already had a pretty sizable salary the
network may not have wanted to pump even
more money into the sitcom sure ratings
were good and good ratings typically
equal lots of network dollars but last
man standing also didn't have the ideal
audience advertisers want viewers in the
18 to 49 age group while the program did
fairly well in that demographic the
show's audience skewed older if
advertisers weren't willing to shell out
the big bucks abc wasn't willing to foot
the growing bill
playing politics after last man
standings cancellation was announced
rumor quickly spread that abc pulled the
plug because of allen's openly
conservative politics the show's premise
rested on an old-school guy who rails
against pc culture and wishes we could
go back to the good old days women want
to have sports sporting events with men
i don't get it because if you beat a
woman you're a bully if you lose to a
woman you're an embarrassment
some suspect the network may have wanted
to distance themselves from that
conservative viewpoint especially since
dungey has previously said donald
trump's presidency has made her rethink
the network's programming slate i think
any woman would know the value of being
compared to such a device like this
but no no no in real life allen is a
proud republican and has stirred up some
controversy with his off-kilter comments
about his status as a rare conservative
in hollywood you got to be real careful
around here you know you get beat up if
you don't believe what everybody
believes it's like 30s germany i don't
know
what happened wisconsin's republican
governor scott walker tweeted his
support to allen stating looks like abc
is playing politics with your show
despite decent ratings sad conservative
pundit glenn beck chimed in during his
online radio show vowing to start
looking into why the show got cancelled
in response to the rumors the network
has insisted politics played no part in
last man standing's demise as abc
president dungey put it i cancelled last
man standing for the same business and
scheduling reasons i cancelled the real
o'neills dr ken the catch and american
crime straightforward as that might
sound it did nothing to stem the tide of
fan outrage when life knocks you down
you don't lie in the canvas crying over
eating like al gore after the 2000
election
he blew up like the hindenburg
fighting back
days after the cancellation was
announced tim allen tweeted that he was
stunned and blindsided by the network i
called home for six years and his fans
were just as irked a change.org petition
to save the show drew more than a
quarter of a million signatures of
support during the days after the show's
fate was sealed though the vocal support
proves the show has a fervent fan base
its chances for finding a new home are
low according to deadline fox considered
taking the show but decided they didn't
have a place on their schedule the
possibility of the show moving to
streaming services or other outlets is
also reportedly remote come on frank
come on my husband will kick your ass
all of the above in the end it looks
like a number of different factors
played into last man standing surprising
cancellation abc is rearranging their
schedule and the show was deceptively
expensive and to think that politics had
absolutely nothing to do with it might
be a bit of a stretch despite the
official line whether a boycott of the
network or a fan petition will
ultimately have much impact remains to
be seen protesters are rarely interested
in facts and unfortunately we don't get
picketed by angry historians
for now at least it looks like the last
man standing probably won't get back up
anytime soon
despite doing well with critics and
having barely gotten started with its
first season something has gotten the
accent dc universe from debunked rumors
to behind the scenes drama here's a look
at everything that led to this comic's
adaptations quick cancellation
the first sign that the series was
stumbling it came even before the first
episode aired on dc universe in late may
2019. in mid-april it was reported
production on swamp thing was being shut
down early and that the show's first
season originally planned for 13
episodes was being whittled down to 10.
there was no word on exactly why swamp
thing's first season was cut short but
the news certainly didn't boost fan
confidence neither did a now deleted
instagram post from one of the series
cast members virginia madsen who played
the troubled maria sunderland and swamp
thing wrote on her instagram page i'm
beyond sad what a terrible decision we
have been cut to the core by those who
have never set foot into the swamp even
executive producer james one admitted to
being baffled by the decision to sink
something although he still encourages
fans to check out the first season in an
instagram post one wrote don't really
know or understand why swamp thing was
cancelled but i can tell you this all
the cast and crew and producing writing
team poured their hearts into this
really proud of everyone's hard work go
watch episode 2 and immortalize these 10
episodes swampy deserves it
one of the earliest and the most
widespread speculations about the show's
sudden cancellation was made by
movies.com writer john golson in a
series of now deleted tweets this story
which has since been debunked is that
something was cut short because of an
accounting error blamed on the state of
north carolina where the series was
filming it's probably just some
accounting error it is not an accounting
error well it could be it is not an
accounting error the story went that
swamp thing's budget was 80 million
dollars and that north carolina through
a program meant to encourage filmmaking
in the states had a promise to cover 40
million dollars of the production costs
through state grants then according to
golson's story someone in the north
carolina government messed up and swamp
things production was only granted 12
million dollars of the promise 40
million dollars so short 28 million
dollars the swamp thing production
close-up shop okay my bad shut it down
that's it
but shortly after golson's story began
to circulate screenranch reported that
his accounting error theory simply
wasn't true swamp thing was granted 12
million dollars for its first season's
production they were also allowed a
separate grant of 4.9 million dollars
for the pilot's episode there was never
a discussion of north carolina picking
up half the bill for swamp thing
according to some the cancellation of
swamp thing doesn't only impact that
series but could threaten every other dc
universe show in june 2018 at t
completed its acquisition of time warner
of which the dc universe streaming
service is apart when deadline reported
swamped things cancellation the outlet
pointed out that quote dc universe is
being reevaluated following the
completion of at t acquisition the
implication seems to be that if one or
media is going to have its own streaming
service a separate dc universe streaming
platform might be considered redundant
if that's the case then producing new
original series in the interim could be
considered a waste
commenting on the cancellation of swamp
thing on the horror website bloody
disgusting writer brad miska speculated
that swamp thing had become quote the
first of probably many scapegoats the
problem miska wrote is that dc universe
was experiencing problems and something
had to give comparing it to amc's
handling of the horror streaming service
shudder he criticized dc universe for
giving up too soon miska certainly could
be right perhaps suffering in marvel's
shadow on the big screen has made time
warner executives more skittish in the
face of anything less than complete and
undeniable success
with some time having passed since swamp
thing's cancellation it now seems like
the series premature ending could be
chalked up to the oldest showbiz
roadblock of all apparently they've got
some real creative differences the
playlist reported that the call to
shorten swamp thing was a creative
decision and not part of a re-evaluation
of dc universe's performance which they
said was quote outpacing expectations
slash film likewise reported the season
truncation was due to creative
differences one of the few sites to
offer any specifics in their update was
bloody disgusting who claimed their
source told them the creative
differences in questions were about the
nature of the series according to the
site some people behind the scenes
wanted swamp thing to be a horror series
it was very important for all of us that
if we've
been grounded more in the horror genre
while others wanted a weekly procedural
we're not sure how anyone pictures a
swamp monster might be able to does
crime scenes for fingerprints but okay
[Music]
joss whedon's firefly was poised to be
the next huge sci-fi series to change
television unfortunately those hopes
were dashed after one incomplete season
let's look back at the reasons why
firefly's lights went out
a small loyal fan base like joss
whedon's other shows buffy the vampire
slayer and angel firefly developed a
strong dedicated fan base unfortunately
the fans weren't in great enough numbers
to halt cancellation despite letter
writing campaigns to keep it alive still
the show's abrupt ending shouldn't be
surprising considering what happened
before it even began production
marriage trouble according to business
insider fox's bigwigs had a problem with
two of the characters zoe and wash being
happily married fox told whedon to nix
their marriage or they'd nixed the deal
whedon revealed in the firefly dvd
commentary that he stuck to his guns
saying then don't pick up the show
because in my show these people are
married ultimately the execs back down
and the show made it to the airwaves but
that didn't mean the troubles ended
friday night fright
firefly was scheduled for friday nights
better known among tv fans as the quote
friday night death slot now airing on
friday nights doesn't automatically
predestine shows for early cancellation
unless that show airs on fox at over 30
television series fox has actually
cancelled more friday night programs
than any other network firefly had a
death sentence right out of the gate the
episodes aired out of order
when whedon conceived the show he
planned it as an episodic yet continuous
story divided into hour-long chunks the
episodes needed to air in a specific
order to make sense to viewers somehow
this went over fox execs's heads
and each chapter a firefly aired out of
order on fox the pilot which introduces
the characters and plot of the entire
venture didn't air until the end of the
show's run
the promos didn't capture the spirit of
the show fox's ads promos and
commercials for firefly failed to
properly convey what the show is about
or what it was in spirit as producer
chris buchanan said in the dvd
commentary the campaign suggested
firefly was a wacky genre comedy when it
wasn't and as author amy pascal wrote in
joss whedon the biography viewers who
would have loved the show were too
alienated to watch it and those who
tuned in because of the promos were
disappointed
low ratings
with everything going against it
firefly's bad ratings were unsurprising
on average it attracted about 4.7
million viewers while that's a huge
number in and of itself it's puny by
network television standards according
to e online firefly finished at 98th
place in the nielsen ratings the show
itself was excellent but fox only cared
about numbers
an executive defense despite all the
obstacles they placed before the show's
success the folks at fox essentially
played dumb when it came to firefly's
cancellation former fox entertainment
president gail berman told the
pittsburgh post gazette having to cancel
it was very difficult
must have been difficult considering she
was part of the decision-making process
that led to the series episodes airing
out of order and on friday nights at
least fans eventually got some closure
in the form of 2005 serenity the big
motion picture follow-up to the series
that's better than some one-season
wonders ever get
the 1990s were a golden age of
television animation but cartoons are a
business and even the most beloved shows
were sometimes cancelled to make room
for more profitable programming here are
the real reasons behind a few of those
controversial cartoon cancellations
after debuting on mtv in 1993 millions
of kids and adults watched the two
giggling moronic metal heads of biebus
and butthead determine which bands were
cool and which sucked that is when they
weren't terrorizing their neighbors
teachers and burger world customers not
everybody liked beavis and butthead
politicians called out the show for
encouraging anti-social behavior and one
family blamed beavis pyromania for
leading to a deadly house fire nothing
stuck though and beavis and butthead
remained the world's favorite idiot
however after 200 episodes and the
feature film beavis and butthead do
america creator mike judge decided it
was time to end it speaking to los
angeles times judge said i actually
wanted to stop a little sooner after the
second season i thought how are we going
to do this anymore i was completely
burned out judge wound up sticking
around for seven seasons but in 1997 he
moved on to other projects like his fox
animated series king of the hill
starring three old-timey cartoon
characters named yakko wacko and dot
warner who were more or less imprisoned
in the water tower on the warner
brothers movie lot animaniacs was a
cartoon quickly embraced by both
children and adult audiences alike
debuting in 1993 animaniacs satirized
cartoon tropes while being completely
self-aware offering up innuendo lace
dialogue and biting social commentary
among the kid-friendly laughs animaniacs
ran for five seasons and spun off its
most popular side characters pinky and
the brain before kids wb ended the show
in 1998 according to creator tom ruger
the end came due to a business decision
regarding another much cheaper kids show
a japanese anime series with massive
commercial potential ruger explained
kids wb was handed pokemon for free and
it pulled down big numbers so then they
wanted everything for free animaniacs
cost warner brothers too much money to
make and promote so off it went
at first glance todd mcfarland's
animated spawn series looked like a show
for kids but spawn was based off of
mcfarland's top selling comic series an
extremely dark and violent story about a
former assassin who gets killed by his
boss sent to hell and ends up working
for satan hardly family-friendly
material you made a deal with male
[Music]
[ __ ] you cut a deal for your soul
spawn ran for three seasons on hbo and
won an emmy award for outstanding
animated program the show's third season
was a bust however and hbo's animation
division was withering on the vine after
enduring numerous production
difficulties the show earned a quiet
cancellation in 1999
batman the animated series represented a
breakthrough in television animation and
comic book adaptation moody quiet and
literally dark it demonstrated that
there was a market for dramatic
superhero content that could appeal to
children and adults this batman was so
highly regarded that fox aired the show
in prime time for a while and in 1993
the studio released batman mask of the
phantasm in theaters voice actor kevin
conroy even tops many lists of the best
batman actors however in 1995 after
three years and 85 episodes the series
left the air according to conroy even
though the audience was still invested
and the actors were willing to continue
the creators had run out of ideas and
wanted to end the show on a high note
they didn't want to
compromise on the quality of what they'd
had and start creating kind of silly
stories
fortunately for batman fans the story
ideas didn't dry up for long a sequel
series to the beloved show debuted a
couple years after its cancellation
bringing back most of the animated
series cast and crew including conroy
the new batman adventures debuted on
kids wb in september of 1997.
originally created for abc the critic
was an animated sitcom about a snobby
hapless new york city movie reviewer
named jay sherman he hates most movies
he sees tries to raise his son as best
as he can and fends off his wacky family
according to john lovitz who provided
the voice of jay we did it for abc and
abc goes we love it and then they
cancelled it after seven shows following
its abc cancellation the critic moved
over to fox and aired immediately after
the simpsons where creators al jean and
mike reese had previously worked as
writers and show runners according to
lovitz the critic brought in excellent
ratings for fox retaining 90 of the huge
simpsons audience and yet in 1994 fox
pulled the plug despite a solid
performance an executive at the network
thought the 8 30 pm sunday time slot
could be better used by a new show gene
explained the guy who ran the network
then john matoyan just didn't like the
show he preferred a show that no one
remembers called house of buggin with
john leguizamo the sketch comedy debuted
in early 1995 in the place of the critic
and lasted a mere 10 episodes
in the fall of 1994 the syndicated
disney afternoon programming block mixed
things up by adding gargoyles to its
lineup of silly cartoons and wacky
adventures this contemplative and
sometimes violent show is stylistically
different from its disney afternoon
predecessors like goof troop tailspin
and ducktales similar in tone and
approach to batman the animated series
gargoyles concerns the day-to-day
activities of magical beings who protect
new york city at night the characters
were architectural gargoyles by day
imbued with the spirits of one
thousand-year-old scottish folk
creatures gargoyles ran for three years
and 78 episodes but was ultimately
cancelled because it wasn't a mega hit
according to the creator greg wiseman it
didn't perform up to expectations disney
really wanted it to outdo mighty morphin
power rangers and it failed to succeed
at that
angry beavers tells the story of two
beaver bachelors named dag and norb who
live in an oregon forest
by 2001 four seasons had aired and
cancellation seemed imminent according
to co-creator keith kachorek we were
significantly over budget behind
schedule and had generally worn out our
welcome realizing that the end was near
kachorek and the rest of the angry
beaver staff decided to go out on a
blaze of glory kachoric and show staff
writer roger eschbacher wrote a script
for a series finale episode called bye
bye beavers an installment equal parts
dark and meta dag and norb come to
realize that they are not real but
cartoons and that their show is about to
be cancelled which means they will cease
to exist at first nickelodeon signed off
on the script but when executives
noticed all the jokes making fun of
nickelodeon they reversed course
according to writer micah wright they
saw it all put together and said wait
this makes us look bad so they killed it
the script was never animated but a
recording of the show's voice actors
reading it was made which leaked online
in 2006.
by 1995 comedy central was experimenting
with original programming and one of its
first new shows was a low budget
animated series with largely improvised
dialogue called dr cat's professional
therapist doc does it bother you when i
touch your face like this a little bit
is that inappropriate inappropriate for
me to hold my hand there for the rest of
therapy nope
it's not appropriate comedian jonathan
katz voiced a therapist whose clients
were all stand-up comedians who'd lay on
his couch and relate neuroses that were
really just bits from their stage
routines he also had a lazy adult son
named ben and attempted to have a social
life
ironically it's dr cat's own success
that led to its demise the show helped
put comedy central on the tv map showing
that the channel had a unique
sensibility and was a home for animated
tv two years after its debut south park
premiered on comedy central and became a
monster hit particularly with young male
viewers dr katz attracted an older
audience and since it wasn't in the
demographic that the now south park
obsessed network was trying to lure it
got cancelled
with the arrival of child-friendly cable
networks like nickelodeon and the
popularity of syndicated shows the
ratings for once beloved saturday
morning cartoons started to slip nbc
president brandon tartikoff analyzed the
budgets and found that the average
saturday morning cartoon cost 300
thousand dollars to produce tartakov and
his team realized that it would be much
cheaper to get rid of the cartoons in
favor of new shows or sports in 1991 nbc
signed a long-term contract with notre
dame to air the college's games on
saturday mornings it cost the network
about 1 million dollars a game which was
still cheaper than programming 6 hours
of cartoons every week plus it could
charge higher advertising rates for
football than it could for kid stuff in
1992 nbc switched to a lineup that
included the today show football games
and a block of low budget sitcoms like
saved by the bell eliminating the entire
1991-1992 saturday morning cartoon
schedule
the 1980s launched a ton of cartoon
franchises only to see many of them
canceled mysteriously was it because of
network politics low toy sales or just
sheer foolishness it turns out it was
often all of those things and more
long before every other podcast started
to feature minor celebrities playing
dungeons and dragons kids could watch
dungeons and dragons the cartoon on cbs
saturday mornings the show followed a
group of young teenagers stranded in the
realm of dungeons and dragons they each
played a role like ranger barbarian or
thief and try to get home while helping
the realm it was the highest rated show
in its time slot for two years and it
lasted three seasons before cancellation
rumors built up over the years about why
the show was cut with the violent
content and the moral panic surrounding
d and d considered possible culprits
a partial answer came from writer
michael reeves who claimed unfortunately
problems with tsr the d and d parent
company ultimately killed the plans for
a new season
mark evaneer who helped develop the show
for tv and wrote the first few episodes
finally set the record straight in 2012
by pointing the finger at declining
ratings he explained as far as i know
the protests were minimal and had no
impact the show simply began losing its
audience as all shows eventually do
robocop isn't the most violent movie to
be adapted into a cartoon for children
that honor surely goes to the rambo
series which birthed rambo the force of
freedom but robocop is a solid second
please put down your
seconds weapons comply
sure the movie itself had plenty of toy
tie-ins but it's still a hard r action
movie nevertheless robocop the animated
series existed in 1988 and had a solid
following the show did make several
alterations in the name of being kid
friendly such as replacing bullets with
laser beams the original plan was to run
for 13 episodes in syndication until the
budget for episode 13 was rerouted so
the series finished at episode 12 with
the money for the plan finale going
instead towards pride of the x-men the
pilot for an x-men series while there
would be many x-men cartoons over the
years pride never came to fruition
meaning one cartoon was canceled and a
failed attempt to start another
the title gi joe a real american hero
can refer to two separate shows the
first is the series made by sunbow
productions that ran from 1983 to 1986.
the second is the one made by dic that
ran from 1989 to 1992. why was there a
gap between two studios telling one
continuous story it turns out that the
first edition was canceled after a
bidding war after producing the first
two seasons of the show sunbow had
detailed plans in place for a third the
joes would go off to fight a new foe
called the coil while cobra commander
would be in the background biting his
time until he could play the coil and
the joes off each other before this
could happen though hasbro changed
things up the toy company had been
self-funding the show with sunbow and
decided to cut production costs
according to gi joe's story editor buzz
dixon the syndication market was
saturated in the mid 80s with more shows
than there were time slots available dic
was a big part of this problem often
underbidding competitors all this led to
hasbro deciding to cut costs by dumping
sunbow after dic offered them a contract
too good to refuse dixon has no kind
words for dic to this day as he put it
in an interview these guys may not have
been 100 responsible for the destruction
of the animation industry in the late
80s but they sure helped
based on the long-running comic strip
garfield and friends was a massive
success worldwide and featured some of
the best animation of its era it lasted
seven seasons and eternity in 80s
cartoon years it was finally cancelled
in 1994 because of budget cuts due to a
changing tv landscape the show was
expensive to produce but the producers
figured that it was worth it selling the
show to cbs and in syndication deals
across the country let them charge a
high license fee and rake in profits
success upped the license fee each year
and eventually cbs wanted to renegotiate
when garfield and friends premiered
cartoons aired almost exclusively on cbs
abc and nbc as the series went on
however fox became a viable network and
entire channels dedicated to animation
like cartoon network popped up or places
to watch cartoons meant that the
audience was spreading thinner which
meant networks became stingier cbs asked
the producers to cut the show's budget
by two-thirds figuring that they made
enough in syndication to handle a
smaller cash flow but the producers did
the math and determined that it wouldn't
work syndication wasn't going to cover
the deficit costs and the show was doing
well and up in reruns so garfield and
friends was cancelled i don't have to
put up with this
there are plenty of people who would
love to have a cat
especially one as adorable as me
voltron was one of the most popular
cartoons of the 80s spawning a franchise
that exists to this day at its peak it
was the number one syndicated children's
show in america after the second season
plans for another were in place but they
never materialized there were several
reasons for this but it all boils down
to two major producers having a falling
out voltron started because producer ted
koppler realized there was a market for
adapting foreign children shows to the
american market he hired peter o'keefe
an energetic man with a real talent for
the business to help localize voltron
for a couple of anime shows and run
production but the tensions boiled
between the two and it all came to a
head in 1989 when o'keefe sued koppler
over breach of contract as o'keeffe felt
that he was owed more money bitter
feelings persisted until the two men
reconciled around 2010 just before
o'keefe passed away it was that piece
that paved the way for today's modern
voltron properties
thundar the barbarian followed thundar
and his friends across a
post-apocalyptic earth the show was
created by ruby spears productions in
1980 and comics legend jack kirby helped
with the design of the show it was
ostensibly a children's show but the
writers aimed for slightly older
audiences despite its popularity it was
cancelled after two seasons in 1981. joe
ruby one half of the namesake of ruby
spears had his own ideas about why as he
put it it was not cancelled from a lack
of ratings i'll tell you that right off
the top it was cancelled i guess because
it was too violent or something like
that that may well have been part of it
but there was an even bigger factor in
play gary marshall wanted its slot
marshall oversaw abc's three biggest
shows at the time happy days laverne and
shirley and mork and mindy what he
wanted the network gave him and what
marshall wanted was animated versions of
his show so as to cover every possible
audience thus to make room for fawns in
the happy days gang thundar was kicked
from the airwaves bonds in the happy
days gang was gone one year later and a
series of shows based on other martial
properties took its place none did as
well as thundar though the danger is
over for now
sunday funny's mainstay heathcliff
appeared in two cartoon adaptations by
two studios two years apart the first
simply titled heathcliff was created by
ruby spears productions and ran on abc
from 1980 to 1981 the second best known
as heathcliff and the cadillac cats was
produced by dic and random syndication
from 1984 through 1985. there hasn't
been a new heap clip cartoon since
because of the loss of legendary lead
voice actor mel blank in an era when
most voice acting was done by character
actors and anonymous voice-over artists
flank was a legitimate superstar on par
with anyone in hollywood he was the
voice of bugs bunny dappyduck and many
others including heathcliff on both of
the cat's shows blank was also a heavy
smoker he smoked a pack a day from when
he was nine until he was 77. he quit
after developing emphysema and spent
most of his last decade revisiting
characters he had played for years
heathcliff was his last new character
according to donna christie who voiced
iggy and cleo on heathcliff and the
cadillac cats the show ended because
blank became too ill to keep doing it
his death in 1989 meant that nobody had
any reason to make more heathcliff
episodes any attempts to revive the show
later were pointless as nobody could
follow blank
most of the shows on this list were
canceled after they got popular but the
garbage pail kids was popular entirely
because it was cancelled before a single
episode had even aired in fact the
garbage pail kids brand started as
trading cards that were created as a
parody of the cabbage patch kids the
garbage pail kids were chock full of
gross out humor and they stirred up a
decent amount of controversy in their
heyday take a card any card you probably
wish you hadn't terry drinkwater
explains that american children these
days are obsessed with the whole
disgusting deck when word got out that
there was going to be a cartoon based on
the cards morality enforcers swooped
into strike the national federation for
decency took off arms with particular
zeal these protests led to advertisers
backing out and some affiliates refusing
to air the show ultimately cbs pulled
the plug on the garbage pail kids before
it could air in america they attempted
to sanitize the show but it just didn't
work the show aired in several other
countries and gained a cult following
through bootlegs and eventually a proper
dvd release one unlikely person who was
happy to see it canceled was mark
newgarden who was part of the team that
created the trading cards he said i've
seen the pilot episode and it's a lame
castrated version of the garbage pail
kids carefully avoiding everything that
made our cards work
and humanoids followed a team of earth
scientists fighting off the title
subterranean beasts it ran for 13
episodes in syndication and was noted
for its monstrous designs and surprising
amount of violence though it had a
following it was canceled after one
season due to a few factors particularly
money the show also generated some
protest due to its brutality which
certainly contributed to the
cancellation while opposition of this
nature didn't help matters the nail in
the coffin could be found in the toy
aisle like many cartoons of the era and
humanoids was designed to sell toys
there was just one problem the toy line
bombed the toys were large in size heavy
and too grotesque to be mainstream they
were so top-heavy in fact that they were
infamous for falling over the show also
appealed to a slightly older audience
one that tends to be less interested in
toys clearly not much was expected of
the toy line either as the show was
canceled before the toys were even
released
though it's mostly remembered for its
live action bit starring lou albano as
mario and danny wells as luigi the super
mario brothers super show is half
cartoon the show was nevertheless labor
intensive for the actors who had to work
six days a week to produce a new episode
every single weekday it was a huge hit
with kids who were almost certainly
thrilled that they could get their fix
of video games and cartoons from the
same source
at the end of the first season order
nintendo simply didn't have any more
interest in the show and didn't renew
their agreement with dic for it in 1990
nintendo and dic teamed up again for the
adventures of super mario bros 3 doing
essentially the same show but without
the live action bits but that show
didn't last very long either as only 13
episodes were produced
for you
it's a tough world out there in the tv
industry for every mega hit there's
another show that fails to find an
audience sometimes it's a reflection on
a series quality but in the era of peak
tv that isn't always the case often
great tv flies under the radar due to
the sheer amount of content viewers have
to choose from every week with that in
mind let's take a look at why these
shows were cancelled in 2018
ash vs evil dead
stars cancelled ash vs evil dead in
april allowing the story to wrap up with
the third season finale a follow-up to
sam raimi's evil dead films the series
brought back bruce campbell as the
titular demon slayer campbell seemed
willing to go on playing ash forever
calling it the role of a lifetime but
stars pulled the plug in an effort to
refine its slate of scripted originals
the series launched with 437
000 same-day viewers but its ratings
fell over its run eventually dropping to
just
175 000 although those numbers probably
jumped when dvr views were added in
that's still a disappointing figure for
an established property with a big name
star
the exorcist
fox's supernatural drama the exorcist a
sequel to the 1973 film of the same name
starred alfonzo herrera and ben daniels
as a pair of priests searching for evil
it was well received by critics but it
never pulled in huge audience numbers
the second season averaged just 1.9
million viewers and only a 0.6 rating in
the key 18 to 49 demo although many fans
were upset showrunner jeremy slater said
that they shouldn't blame the network
for its decision he tweeted i know it's
easy to get angry at fox but the reality
is that we were the lowest rated drama
on any network and they still brought us
back for a second season because they
loved the show there are no bad guys in
this scenario
the last man on earth
fox sitcom the last man on earth had its
last season on earth in 2018. it starred
will forte as the lone survivor of a
lethal worldwide virus or at least he
seemed to be alone at first he was
eventually joined by other survivors
including characters played by kristen
schall january jones mel rodriguez
cleopatra coleman and mary steenburgen
the fourth and final season ended on a
cliffhanger leaving fans hugely
disappointed the series was the casualty
of a fox comedy blitz as the network
cancelled all of its live-action sitcoms
the show did earn five emmy nominations
over its run including two for forte but
that wasn't enough to keep it on the air
it's enough to make you sick
oh my god
lucifer
the devil was officially out at fox in
2018 when the network canceled lucifer
after three seasons the show starred tom
ellis as the fallen angel who had
retired from hell and moved to los
angeles working double duty as a
nightclub owner and a consultant for the
lapd although lucifer averaged just 4.1
million viewers and a 1.1 rating in the
18 to 49 demo in its last season it was
still beloved by fans who immediately
started campaigning to find a new home
for the drama their enthusiasm paid off
as netflix picked up lucifer for a
fourth season sometimes it pays to make
a deal with the devil
the mick
caitlyn olsen has enjoyed a long run on
it's always sunny in philadelphia so you
guys what's the deal with those
hands-free headsets that everybody's
wearing in their ears right
but her luck wasn't quite as good for
her fox sitcom the mick which was
canceled after just two seasons olson
played mickey an irresponsible wild
child who gets stuck with taking care of
her sister's rich spoiled children
although the mick received a mostly
positive critical reception it failed to
build on its mild buzz averaging just
3.1 million viewers over its two seasons
that might have been good enough for
renewal in a normal year but with fox's
acquisition of nfl thursday night
football the network had much less space
on its schedule the mick was just one of
several casualties nikki it was one
thing when you were squatting in her
mansion but now you're costing us money
all right all right mozart in the jungle
amazon left the music behind in 2018
cancelling its drama mozart in the
jungle after four seasons based on
oboist blair tendahl's 2005 memoir the
show starred gail garcia bernal as the
new conductor of the new york symphony
the show was critically acclaimed
winning golden globes for best series
and best actor for bernal in 2016. its
cancellation comes as amazon tries to
shift its programming toward bigger
dramas with more international appeal in
the vein of hbo's massively successful
game of thrones mozart was just the
first casualty of this new directive
once upon a time
abc's fairy tale drama once upon a time
has lost a lot of viewers over the years
but it managed to stay popular enough
with a loyal group of fans to earn an
unexpected 7th season renewal in 2017
that renewal also came with a massive
creative overhaul with much of the
principal cast replaced by newcomers
despite the reboot once upon a time
still struggled in the ratings and
season 7 became its last abc
entertainment president channing dungey
called it a bittersweet goodbye with the
show averaging 2.5 million viewers down
20 from the year before the writing was
clearly on the wall
the path
it seemed like hulu landed something big
with the path starring a fresh off
breaking bad aaron paul and golden globe
nominee michelle monaghan as husband and
wife members of a cult-like religion
despite the series impressive pedigree
it only lasted three seasons hulu
doesn't release ratings so it's unclear
what kind of viewership the show was
pulling in but it never received the
critical acclaim to match its premise
and cast while it garnered decent
reviews the fact that it never received
any major awards nominations was
probably the nail in the coffin the
leads expensive paychecks probably
didn't help either
roseanne
abc's roseanne reboot was met with
controversy right out of the gate thanks
to star roseanne barr's politics which
eventually led to the sitcom getting
pulled off the air abc reversed its
initial renewal decision after barr
tweeted racist and islamophobic
statements about former white house
advisor valerie jarrett announcing the
show's cancellation abc entertainment
president channing dungey said
roseanne's twitter statement is
abhorrent repugnant and inconsistent
with our values and we have decided to
cancel her show i was being nice she's a
crazy stupid hillbilly it was a stunning
decision considering that roseanne was
the highest rated scripted show on
broadcast television that season
averaging 19.3 million viewers
ultimately those numbers were too good
for abc to let go of completely a
roseanne free spin-off dubbed the
connors was announced in late june
shades of blue
jennifer lopez's star power wasn't
enough to keep her cop drama shades of
blue on the air starring lopez as a
single mother and nypd detective
recruited to work on the fbi's
anti-corruption task force the show was
canceled after three seasons the final
season is currently airing over the
summer lopez who also serves as an
executive producer has said that there
will be a poetic three-season arc to the
way her character story ends although
averaging 7 million viewers in season 2
it seems that keeping a star as pricey
as lopez wasn't worth it for nbc
taken
being based on a well-known film series
isn't enough to ensure a tv show's
success such was the case for the nbc
drama taken a prequel to the liam neeson
flicks of the same name the show which
starred clive standin as a younger
version of neeson's brian mills was
cancelled after airing two seasons it
followed mills during his days as a
former green beret and member of an
elite team of covert operatives tasked
with conducting dangerous rescue
missions around the world after a
lackluster critical reception in season
one taken experienced a major cast
overhaul and brought on a new showrunner
for year two but that wasn't enough the
show was nbc's lowest rated drama in the
18 to 49 demo mills may have a very
special set of skills but bringing in
viewers apparently isn't one of them
timeless
timeless came back from cancellation
once but it couldn't pull off that same
trick twice the show starred abigail
spencer malcolm barrett and matt lanter
as a history professor scientist and
soldier tasked with traveling through
time to prevent the alteration of
history it struggled in the ratings from
the get-go and thanks to an expensive
budget due to constant changes in
costumes and settings nbc decided to
pull the plug after its first season
however the network wound up reversing
that decision just a few days later
after fan outcry from viewers who dubbed
themselves clock blockers although those
fans were just as active on social media
calling for a renewal after season two's
cliffhanger ending nbc ultimately
cancelled the show again thanks to
continued lackluster ratings and this
time it looks like it's permanent
the 1990s brought a tidal wave of
sitcoms crashing onto the shores of tv
some were amazing others were terrible
but all of them eventually came to an
end keep watching to discover the most
interesting stories of 90s sitcom
cancellation
news radio was one of the most acclaimed
sitcoms of the decade but all of its
positive critical notice came in spite
of or perhaps because of battles with
its network creator paul sims fought
with nbc over everything from scheduling
to plot lines by his telling nbc wanted
more established stars dave foley andy
dick and joe rogan were all well known
in the world of comedy but they weren't
exactly household names throughout
america in 1997 sims who was almost
certain that his show was getting
cancelled gave a profanity-laced
interview to rolling stone he admonished
nbc for not giving news radio a slot on
thursday night's must-see tv lineup and
he called out executives by name
afterwards the show was briefly
cancelled before being brought back
which led to everyone awkwardly walking
back what they said and playing nice the
dynamic of the show changed
significantly in season 5 following the
death of phil hartman he was something
of a big brother to the rest of the cast
and addressing his death resulted in an
uncomfortable tonal shift hartman's old
snl castmate john lovitz was added to
the news radio cast but he never quite
clicked it also didn't help that preston
beckman nbc's head of scheduling at the
time despised the show during news
radio's run it changed time slots 11
times amidst all this turmoil it was
cancelled after the fifth season
sports night aaron sorkin's dramedy
about the behind the scenes of a
sportscenter type show was never a
rating success but it almost didn't
matter it was critically acclaimed it
won awards and the viewers who did watch
it were a passionate bunch when fans got
a sense that sports night wasn't long
for this world they set up websites
petitioning to save it when abc acts the
show several other networks including
usa hbo and showtime expressed interest
in picking it up negotiations with
showtime went furthest with sorkin
claiming that they offered him about 37
million dollars for two more seasons
that much money on a network where
ratings weren't critically important was
an almost perfect scenario but alas
sorkin had no choice but to turn it down
that was because during sports night's
second season he created a little show
called the west wing for nbc he did
almost all of the writing for both shows
splitting his days between the two of
them also around this time his wife was
pregnant and he realized he couldn't
give his all to sports night anymore
showtime didn't want to enter into a
heavy commitment without sorkin going
all in so negotiations ended
home improvement was without a doubt one
of the most popular sitcoms of the 90s
it spent its entire eight season run
rated in the top ten and the series
finale aired on a third of all tvs in
america but there was never a ninth
season because stars tim allen and
patricia richardson both wanted to move
on richardson was offered 30 million
dollars for another year but she turned
it down because she decided to focus on
her family she was a single mother to
three children and home improvement was
keeping her away from them too much alan
meanwhile was at the most bankable point
in his career during his run on home
improvement he starred in major box
office hits like the santa claus toy
story and jungle to jungle hollywood was
calling and besides no matter how much
he was offered he didn't want to do the
show without richardson
well
that just shows how smart you are
long before she played a neurobiologist
on the big bang theory mayam bialik was
an average teenage girl on the family
sitcom blossom the show had a dedicated
audience before it ended after five
seasons it was cancelled for three main
reasons the stars were getting older the
audience was aging out and it had tough
competition in the form of melrose place
the thing about shows focused on
teenagers is that they always grow up
eventually the final episode of blossom
sees the title character getting ready
for college and a life utterly unlike
the one fans fell in love with the
primary audience for these shows tends
to be tween girls and their tastes
change and mature as they grow up so
shows like blossom tend to have a shelf
life especially when more mature
programs like melrose place are around
blossom for its part did tackle some
touchy subjects that became part of the
show's dna this kept it relevant but it
couldn't save it entirely kids learned
some important lessons from blossom
about topics like divorce and addiction
but then they grew past it
dinosaurs was a strange show there's no
other way to put it in many ways it was
a normal sitcom about a suburban family
dealing with everyday issues except for
the fact that every cast member was a
dinosaur puppet the show nevertheless
somehow had some of the sharpest writing
on tv of its era and it was without
question one of the most visually
interesting shows of the decade alas the
cost of dinosaurs sophisticated puppetry
ultimately made it unsustainable
especially when ratings started to dip
rumors spread that it was the most
expensive half hour on television
eventually it just wasn't worth what it
cost to make and so abc cancelled it but
the writers weren't interested in going
gently into the good night as they
decided to make one of the most bonkers
series finales in tv history entitled
changing nature the episode sees the
dinosaurs try to handle an invasive
plant species by accidentally setting
off an ice age that leads to the
extinction of the entire species the
script prompted a call from abc's
president asking the writers where they
got the hutzpah to kill off the entire
cast the writers responded that they
were inspired by the planet's actual
history in the words of series creator
michael jacobs when you do a show about
dinosaurs you always have that
extinction card in your pocket and we
wanted to use it
ellen made television history in 1997
with the puppy episode in which the main
character played by ellen degeneres
comes out of the closet
susan
i'm gay
while this has endured as a landmark
moment in tv history it also proved to
be the beginning of the end for the show
as a combination of backlash and weird
creative decisions caused ratings to
plummet during ellen's fourth season
degeneres and abc were fighting about
the show's content network executives
were reluctant to let ellen come out and
they started putting content warnings
before episodes degeneres objected to
this and threatened to walk before
making a fifth season media discussion
about the show after the puppy episode
aired was growing more and more complex
chaz bono at the time the media director
of glaad worried that the show was
leaning in a little too much as he put
it it's one thing to have a gay lead
character but it's another when every
episode deals with pretty specific gay
issues ultimately ellen was canceled
after five seasons though its legacy
lives on to this day
grace under fire was an early project
for chuck lorre who would go on to
create such series as two and a half men
and the big bang theory like many of his
future shows it was a raiding success
the title character a divorced mother
and recovering alcoholic was played by
brett butler the show soared on the
wings of her talent and eventually
struggled as her real-life problems
intruded onto the set the departure of
two cast members and five executive
producers were all attributed to
butler's erratic behavior and drug
addiction during a crossover event
production teams from other shows were
especially horrified the crew for the
drew carey show even got t-shirts that
said i survived breath grace under
fire's production was halted on at least
two occasions for butler to attend rehab
both times resulted in long delays both
added to her bad reputation and both
contributed to a ratings decline
eventually abc got fed up and pulled the
plug butler is now clean and sober and
has expressed remorse for how she
behaved at the time
salute your shorts was one of
nickelodeon's first big live-action
success stories following a group of
kids at a summer camp it paved the way
for the success of future sitcoms aimed
at kids in the following decades two
seasons were produced successfully on a
shoestring budget but then production
changes forced the cancellation in june
1990 nickelodeon studios opened in
orlando florida going forward the
network intended to have all of its
programming shot there salute your
shorts had been recorded in los angeles
up to that point and it struggled to
adapt to the change in location the cast
was primarily children and teenagers who
all decided that it wasn't worth it to
move across the country hey dude one of
nick's other live-action comedies faced
the same predicament ultimately with
nobody moving both shows were cancelled
the nanny was so popular in the 90s that
anyone who watched back then can still
hear fran drescher's laugh right now
from sensememory
despite lasting six seasons the show's
cancellation came as something of a
shock years later drescher attributed it
to her character fran fine finally
acting on a romantic tension with max
sheffield will they won't they
storylines permeate many long-running
sitcoms and their culmination always
changes the dynamic of a show with the
tension gone viewers theoretically have
less of a reason to tune in and writers
then have to come up with new storylines
drescher initially had no interest in
having fran pair up with max but she was
forced into the decision after the
network threatened cancellation as she
put it in 2017 when a show is built
around a love that can't happen you have
to keep it that way she may have just
been right about that as ratings
plummeted after the wedding and the show
was off the air a season later
veronica's closet was never a critical
darling but that didn't matter at least
for a while when a show on nbc is
produced by the same team that made
friends it automatically has some sway
instead of good reviews veronica's
closet got something better a 9 30 p.m
thursday night time slot on nbc this was
smack dab in the middle of the must-see
tv lineup right between seinfeld and er
during its first season and between
frasier and er during its second ratings
were great during this time until they
started to taper off towards the end of
season two bad critical notice also
caught up to it and audiences were
growing less and less interested nbc
responded to this ratings dip by
transferring veronica's closet to monday
evenings alongside suddenly susan some
observers saw this as a way to dump
shows that were underperforming nbc had
openly promised critics and fans that
the show would improve and they even
brought on new writers from friends to
help it out ultimately none of this
tinkering mattered as the monday time
slot killed it without a loyal following
veronica's closet cratered in the
ratings on its way to getting cancelled
suddenly susan had a lot going for it it
had the support of a major network a
solid cast headlined by brook shields
and one of the best time slots on tv
season one aired on thursday nights at 9
30 pm right between seinfeld and er when
it was moved to mondays the ratings took
a steep drop though they were still
decent but around the end of the third
season suddenly susan was facing many
challenges cast member david strickland
took his own life which was a major blow
to the rest of the cast and crew
furthermore during the off season almost
the entire creative team left as did
actor judd nelson he was replaced in the
final season by eric idle but it wasn't
enough between an unfamiliar creative
team and an unfavorable time slot
suddenly susan dropped in the ratings
like a stone and it was canceled
mid-season the remaining episodes were
burned off in the summer
you ever feel frustrated when a show
wraps up before the long summer hiatus
and leaves things unresolved hey it's
just a season finale you'll get closure
when that show returns in the fall but
then there are some long-running tv
shows that ended a season on their
cliffhanger and then got cancelled here
are some shows where audiences never got
to find out what happened morgan mindy
elevated by the staggering comic gifts
of robin williams this show's fourth
season run came to an end in a truly
weird fashion an evil alien named
kellnick tries to kill mork and mindy
but they escape using a pair of magical
time travelling shoes but oops they're
damaged and the pair go too far back in
time the last image a cave painting of
mork and mindy did they ever get back to
the future we'll never know because the
show got cancelled sliders on the final
installment of sliders a show featuring
a cast of dimension hopping characters a
psychic tells the crew that if they
slide through space and time just once
more they'll die however they find a
loophole if one of them slides but also
injects themselves with a special tonic
they'll be okay the character rembrandt
does it and slides on through does he
live does he die the psychic could tell
the others but while fighting off the
team's enemies she dies
freaks and geeks freaks and geeks made
stars out of the cast members like james
franco and seth rogen but when this show
aired in 1999 it finished near the
bottom of the ratings nbc cancelled it
before all 18 episodes were broadcast
one of the season's story arcs followed
lindsay weir and her struggles with
whether or not to remain a hard-working
school-first good girl she ultimately
ditches an academic summit to go to a
grateful dead concert at the end lindsay
hops in a van and it drives away and we
never know if lindsay made it there or
back
my name is earl
this sitcom followed around an amiable
dirtbag named earl played by jason lee
who wins the lottery and spends his life
making amends for all the bad things
he's done despite being a big hit for
nbc it was abruptly cancelled at the end
of season 4 in 2009 the last scene drops
a bombshell earl's actually the father
of his ex-wife's baby and she's about to
explain
but the episode and series ends with a
to be continued graphic nbc
that's for canceling my name is earl
lois and clark the new adventures of
superman each decade gets the superman
it deserves sad post watergate 70s
america got happy positive christopher
reeve and superficial melrose place
loving 90s america got this soapy super
show starring dean kane and terry
hatcher season four ended with a super
seeming baby left on lois and clark's
doorstep was it from krypton like
superman who knows abc decided a fifth
season wasn't such a super idea angel
toward the end of its run angel and his
gang take on an evil law firm of wolfram
and heart the final scene of season 5
shows the protagonists preparing to
storm their enemies the show's creative
team didn't intend for this to be the
ending but they learned too late that
they weren't getting renewed so they
ended the show on a cliffhanger but
creator joss whedon is okay with that
satisfied it suggests the fight against
evil never truly ends
despite being among the most remarkable
and ambitious shows in tv history hbo
unceremoniously cancelled deadwood after
just three seasons in 2019 13 years
later the show finally returned with a
wrap-up film so just why did hbo get rid
of deadwood in the first place
the business of making television is
somewhat separate from the business of
broadcasting it while many networks are
part of entertainment conglomerates that
also include production companies the
studios that make tv shows can shop a
series around to different networks
which then pay a hefty licensing fee for
the right to air it studios may also
team up to make shows particularly
expensive ones like deadwood hbo is a
division of warner media and the network
co-produced a show with paramount which
held the international rights that
necessitated a lot of talks and
contracts between warner and paramount
over splitting the profits from deadwood
those companies reached an impasse about
their arrangement before a fourth season
of deadwood could go into production and
so both parties walked away from the
table in effect canceling the show
and here's my counteroffer to your
counteroffer
go
yourself
that may not be as exciting as a
standoff in the thoroughfare but it's
the reality
then hbo chief executive and chairman
chris albrecht told the chicago tribune
not having a fourth season of deadwood
is not the result anyone wanted by that
time the possibility had disappeared
like a deadminer's body into mr wu's
pigpen but the network really did fight
to keep deadwood alive hbo wanted
creator david milch to concentrate his
efforts on his next show for the network
the surreal spiritual and short-lived
surfing drama jon from cincinnati so
executives offered him a six-episode
final season of deadwood as opposed to
the traditional 12. he turned it down
milch said it seemed to me that some
sort of partial order for the show would
make it impossible to do anything but
superimpose all sorts of interpretations
that would deprive it of its own emotion
then just days before deadwood's third
and final season premiered in 2006 hbo
announced that those episodes would not
be the end of the line as the network
had accepted milch's pitch to wrap up
the series with a pair of two-hour
specials network spokesperson nancy
lesser said he found a way to bring
closure to the narrative and remain true
to the themes of the material and spirit
of the characters those two specials
ended up as just one movie released 13
years later
deadwood wasn't just canceled because
the people who write the checks had a
fight about money it also earned a de
facto cancellation because of some
passive aggressive behavior by hbo
according to tv series finale deadwood
wasn't officially cancelled at all the
cast so-called options simply weren't
picked up an option is a clause in an
actor's contract that gives your show's
production company the chance to sign
the performer on for more episodes at
the end of the contract's term in the
case of deadwood actors contracts were
valid for three seasons with an option
for a fourth this binds an actor to a
show preventing them from leaving to
make other tv shows or movies thus
saving writers from the task of
explaining character absences but the
fourth season option for deadwood stars
was an exercise the actors were
essentially released from their
obligation to deadwood meaning they were
available to go do other things hbo and
the show's producers essentially said
you're no longer needed which is just
another way of saying show's over go
home no deceit
too prolonged no hearing too demeaning
get out of here
no rebuke too vile
television is a numbers game by and
large the shows that bring in the most
overall viewers are the ones that get a
rubber stamp renewal season after season
hbo is an ad-free network and operates
on a paid subscription model but it
still has to take ratings into effect if
it errors shows that not enough people
are watching then it's a waste of the
company's money it's also not going to
bring in many more people willing to pay
an extra 10 to 20 dollars a month on
their cable bill this was the problem
with deadwood despite the critical
praise and awards attention from the
emmys and golden globes it never exactly
pulled in game of thrones level numbers
the first season of deadwood averaged a
respectable 4.5 million viewers but only
about 2.4 million viewers cared enough
about al sweringen and seth bullock to
tune in for season two a downward
ratings trajectory made an early
cancellation inevitable
every episode of deadwood was densely
packed with inscrutable characters and
complicated dialogue to inform within
decency's limits we've had this
discussion before citizens better die
postulating than touching decent ink
deadwood was already a difficult show to
make even before creator david milch's
tendency toward last minute rewrites
according to indy wire actor timothy
oliphant told the audience that film
independent presents an evening with
deadwood about the time milch came to
him in his trailer to tell him that he
just decided to kill off bullock's
stepson which required a complete
reworking of the show oliver joked the
season became about that kid dying the
decision happened at lunch according to
vulture milch was a consummate
perfectionist who hung out on the
deadwood set barking out dialogue
suggestions from off camera and ordering
scenes re-shot even if he wasn't the
credited writer or director ian mcshane
who played swearingen remembers rewrites
coming in so late that the pages were
still warm from the copy machine more
takes means more money and deadwood
wasn't a cheap show to begin with
period-appropriate sets and costumes
horses wagons animal handlers and a
large regular cast all contributed to a
budget of around 4.5 million dollars per
episode at its most expensive it must
have been hard for hbo to justify
keeping deadwood around when it didn't
bring in huge ratings
long before the era of peak tv brought
high quality content to most every cable
network and streaming service hbo held
itself up as the home of prestige
television bearing the famous slogan
it's not tv it's hbo the premium channel
carefully selects what handful of shows
it will air at any given time and while
it tries to offer a little something for
everyone it can often find itself with a
certain brand in the mid 2000s the
flavor of hbo was solidly hip envelope
pushing shows set in the present day a
sampling of its lineup at the time
included curb your enthusiasm the
comeback extras the sopranos and big
love among those shows about cranky tv
riders deluded actresses cranky british
actors depressed mob bosses and plural
marriage sat deadwood and often brutal
slow-moving western where the characters
talk like they were doing shakespeare
with more profanity it was an anomaly on
hbo's schedule and it was simply too
weird to live always superfluous
bloodshed
the deeper damage is best
while deadwood was never a raiding smash
casting directors and filmmakers were
among those aware of the show's
undeniably talented ensemble cast by the
show's third season in 2006 many
deadwood performers were already looking
to move on to other roles and other
challenges ian mcshane had roles in a
number of films lined up including voice
work in the golden compass and kung fu
panda and live action parts in hot rod
and the seeker the dark is rising molly
parker showed up in hollywood land and
the wicker man along with another period
series the 70s sets cbs drama swing town
timothy oliphant jumped right back in to
live free or die hard and hitman for
many parties deadwood's cancellation
came at the right time in their careers
a cult classic beloved by its legions of
devoted fans veronica mars put a fresh
spin on the tv mystery genre former
young adult novel author rob thomas
created the show a modern-day
combination of noir and nancy drew and
it ran for three seasons on upn and the
cw years later the show would be
resurrected as a successfully
crowdfunded movie let's explore the real
reasons why veronica mars was cancelled
low ratings
television networks are businesses and
low rated shows tend to be poor
investments
this serves as a preemptive apology for
the conversation that's about to take
place in its first season back in fall
of 2004 veronica mars ranked a dismal
148 out of 156 total shows it ticked up
a bid to 145 in its second season and
138 in its third and final year all the
while total viewership held steady at
about 2.5 million viewers
said cw entertainment president don
ostrof at a tv industry event shortly
after the cancellation we really tried
every single year to bring in more
viewers and we just weren't able to
crack it maybe that's true but the
network didn't do veronica mars any
favors by scheduling it against fox's
american idol at the peak of its
popularity
that is slightly disturbing
tough fit with the cw in 2006 the two
struggling networks the wb and upn
merged into a new network called the cw
which became veronica mars's new home
this face right here
my over the moon face sadly despite
surviving the merger it wasn't an easy
fit even though cw corporate sibling
warner brothers studios produced
veronica mars it was cancelled because
it couldn't draw in new viewers
so are you gonna tell me why i'm here or
should i just sit back and enjoy your
impression of a mildly constipated david
caruso that's because the cw was going
after a couple of very specific audience
niches and veronica mars a difficult to
categorize show that was a little funny
and a little dramatic didn't fit in with
the vampires and superheroes ahead of
its time veronica mars ran on broadcast
tv just before the so-called second
golden age of television and before
streaming services open up new
opportunities for quirkier shows like
the kind rob thomas creates before shows
like breaking bad and game of thrones
found accolades for their intricate
plotting that required viewers to pay
close attention and watch every episode
tv shows that dared to be innovative
cinematic and complicated were often
critically acclaimed but commercially
ignored veronica mars aired around the
same time as arrested development
another show that pulled in a small but
devoted audience of fans who appreciated
precision
cuckoo
yeah what are you doing my plan women
no reboot while veronica mars was still
in the air some cw executives asked
thomas to write a show about rookie cops
he countered with the idea of making the
fourth season of veronica mars jump
forward in time to show veronica and her
first year as an fbi agent and they
produced a pilot presentation a mini
episode about 12 minutes long while well
received by the cw brass the reboot
wasn't meant to be thomas explained in
an interview that he thinks cbs
president les moonves killed it we went
from dead to back on the air to dead
again very quickly our hail mary pass
came very close to working but didn't
quite get past all the filters he needed
to
moving on
probably seeing the writing on the wall
thomas had already secured his next gig
by the time the series was wrapping up
its third season those days are over and
it's time to move on he was hired on as
a writer and producer for abc's
misguided a sitcom starring judy greer
as a high school guidance counselor
thomas was quickly promoted to show
runner and executive producer but left
the series after only a few weeks due to
creative differences misguided was
ultimately a mid-season replacement that
aired only seven episodes in the spring
of 2008 freeing up grier to move on to
better things
resurrection
veronica mars hardcore fans couldn't let
go and neither could the show's talent
for years after the cancellation rob
thomas and star kristen bell mentioned
the possibility of a movie in interviews
it seemed like a long shot for a studio
to finance a big screen version of a
show very few people watched what are we
gonna do this whole veronica mars movie
huh
i don't know you got a couple million
dollars lying around but then along came
kickstarter in march 2013 thomas
launched a campaign to finance the movie
directly from fans within 30 days the
project had collected an astonishing 5.7
million dollars wait for it
[Music]
i love all 91 000 of you from the whole
cast thank you so very very much
thomas took a screenplay and his
kickstarter money to warner brothers and
the studio kicked in a few more million
to get the movie made it was released to
theaters and the video on demand
platforms in march 2014.
some of the best tv series of all time
were cancelled too soon but those
overlooked classics at least had enough
episodes aired to build up a fan base
that was devastated when the shows were
pulled before their time imagine how it
must feel to be a creator producer or
star of a tv series that performs so
poorly that it was ripped off the air
after only a single episode here are
some shows that share that very
unfortunate distinction
coed fever
the biggest movie comedy of 1978 was
national lampoon's animal house so
naturally all three broadcast tv
networks at the time looked to cash in
on the craze cbs's attempt coed fever
was cancelled before it even debuted in
its regular time slot thwarting
countless wacky hijinks
to the ceiling after the tv premiere of
rocky in 1979 cbs had some time to fill
and aired a special preview of the show
which was set on the campus of a former
women's college that had just started
admitting men while the show ranked a
reasonable 19th in the nielsen ratings
for the week it lost so much of the
rocky audience that cbs shut it down
completely
public morals
in the 80s and 90s producer stephen
bochko the creator of critically
acclaimed hit shows such as nypd blue
hill street blues and l.a law was just
about the king of tv cbs jumped at the
chance to get into the bocco business
and committed the laugh track laden
public morals to its fall 1996 schedule
ratings and reviews for its october
debut were dismal and a show about a
vice squad also suffered from bad timing
it premiered in an election year that
included a debate over whether tv was
growing too vulgar because of shows like
public morals cbs canceled it after just
one controversial airing
emily's reasons why not
abc reportedly spent five million
dollars on an ad campaign for the
mid-season launch of emily's reasons why
not a 2006 sitcom about how dating is
hard and weird starring the always
likable heather graham graham starred as
emily a woman unlucky in love trying to
figure out who not to date and why
viewers must have decided there were
plenty of reasons why not to give the
show a chance it lost more than a third
of the audience of its lead-in and lost
a quarter of the audience of the
bachelorette the show that had occupied
its time slot a year earlier which led
to abc immediately pulling the plug
secret talents of the stars
one part circus of the stars one part
american idol this reality competition
show featured celebrities known for one
talent demonstrating a different talent
the general public didn't know they had
just over 4.5 million people tuned in to
watch to mention just one representative
example country singer clint black try
stand up comedy i am going to use index
cards tonight viewers at home were
supposed to vote for their favorites
each week had cbs not cancel the show
after its first episode in 2008
quarter life
high quality tv streaming on the
internet it's common today but in 2008
it was revolutionary marshall herskovitz
and edward zwick creators of critically
acclaimed dramas 30-something and my
so-called life debuted quarter life on
myspace which was a hot social media
platform at the time the show was made
to reflect its medium episodes were
short and resembled youtube clips and it
looked like it was shot on webcams or
hidden cameras while there was no real
precedent for what constituted a hit
streaming series in 2008 enough people
watched that nbc decided to put it on
terrestrial television after taking a
few episodes and pacing them together to
fit an hour-long programming block its
premiere brought in just 3.1 million
viewers the worst mid-season ratings of
an nbc show in nearly two decades the
network canceled the show and dumped the
five remaining prepared episodes onto
its cable counterpart bravo
south of sunset
eagles singer and guitarist glenn frye
didn't fare nearly as well in his foray
into dramatic television as he done with
smooth california rock very few viewers
got a peaceful easy feeling with south
of sunset a lightly comic detective show
in which frye starred as a former movie
studio security chief who opens his own
private investigations company in
beverly hills despite cbs frequently
airing ads for the show during its
broadcast of the 1993 world series just
before the premiere episode only 9 of
viewers tuned their dials to south of
sunset the los angeles times reported
that the show amassed the lowest premier
ratings on record for a show on one of
the big three networks to date cbs put
the show on hiatus almost immediately
but south of sunset never returned to
the schedule
osborne's reloaded an attempted revival
of mtv's the osborne's osborne's
reloaded debuted in a plum post-american
idol time slot in 2009. it presented
metal god ozzy osbourne and his family
at the center of a variety show
featuring pre-taped segments sketches
audience participation bits and musical
performances following a high-profile
preview episode nearly one in five fox
affiliates refused to air further
episodes of osborne's reloaded due to
concerns over racy material and bad
language critics were brutal the
washington post called it a revolting
debacle and must flee tv fox didn't even
bother to air the rest of the episodes
already in the can
lawless
fox apparently didn't learn much from
cbs's disastrous south of sunset and
ordered up another series about a
private investigator starring a famous
non-actor lawless starred standout
university of oklahoma linebacker and
seattle seahawks washout brian the boss
bosworth as an ex-special forces tough
guy named john lawless who unravels
mysteries in miami very few people
wanted to see the boss off the gridiron
and fox canceled the 1997 series after
its premiere episode this just doesn't
seem to be your lucky day
network executives are paid to make the
tough decisions and sometimes they're
also paid to make weird and bizarre
decisions like canceling your favorite
show for no apparent reason if you ever
thought show business made sense well
think again
here's a look at the dumb reasons these
tv shows were cancelled police squad
goals
lots of movies are made out of tv shows
but the three naked gun movies probably
marked the first time a successful
series of films were spawned from an
incredibly unpopular tv show nice bieber
thank you
i just had it stuffed let me help you
with that filled with sight gags and
reoccurring jokes police squad starring
leslie nielsen as lieutenant frank
drebin hit the airwaves in 1982 and was
pulled after just four episodes with the
remaining two burned off over the summer
abc president tony thermopolis was
surprisingly frank about why people
weren't tuning in he told reporter that
quote the viewer had to watch it to
appreciate it that's right police squad
asked that its audience tried the crazy
thing where they pay attention to what's
happening on the screen apparently the
jokes on abc's hit shows happy days and
the love boat were so simple they could
be understood by osmosis
[Music]
[Applause]
long in the tooth
pulling in roughly three to five million
viewers per week longmire was a e's most
watched original drama ever and was
among the top rated dramas on cable tv
during its three season run yet the
network cancelled it anyway why because
most of those fans were too damn old yes
tv networks are pretty much only
interested in courting the key 18 to 49
demographic which advertisers think is
the easiest group to part from their
money so because longmire's audience
wasn't gullible enough a e canceled it
no worries though the show was picked up
by netflix which doesn't have to worry
about advertising trends to rule for
prime time
during the 1969
tv season cbs chief of programming fred
silverman noticed that the shows getting
the best advertising rates were abc and
nbc shows aimed at young and hip viewers
with multicultural casts in urban
environments cbs's shows on the other
hand were mostly rural family shows
silverman's solution cancel all his farm
shows and replace them with cutting edge
new city sitcoms
outwent the red skelton show petticoat
junction greenacres lassie and the gym
neighbor's hour replacing them honest to
goodness classics including the mary
tyler moore show all in the family good
times mod and the bob newhart show
ratings surged among younger
demographics and silverman's move became
hollywood legend known ever after as the
great rule purge
the wrong kind of smart
for 26 years levar burton's beloved
reading rainbow helped kids develop a
love of reading but in 2009 budget
restrictions forced the show's
cancellation because it wasn't educating
kids in a government-approved fashion
weird right well it all started with the
no child left behind act signed into law
in 2002 it sought to establish new
educational benchmarks for american kids
many of which would be measured with
standardized test results in that box is
the bill
i don't intend to read at all
that's fine for quantifiable skills but
it's hard to measure love of reading on
a standardized test
so there went the funding but hope is
not lost thanks to an incredibly
successful kickstarter campaign reading
rainbow is poised for a 21st century
comeback i
am overwhelmed thank you so
much this is going to enable us to
really really really do a lot of good
marvel's runaways is being run off the
air on monday november 18th hulu
announced that runaways will end after
its fast approaching third season set to
hit the disney owned streaming platform
on december 13th deadline confirmed the
news further noting that fans will get
closure with runaway season 3 which is
said to bring the narrative to a quote
natural close and neatly wrap up the
story that follows six teenage heroes
whose parents belong to a coalition of
super villains so what really happened
to push marvel tv and hulu to axe the
show well you can blame the numbers for
that it's always the numbers sure fans
adored the show and critics were kind to
it but runaways was actually performing
worse than his fellow marvel superhero
series you know the ones that were all
cancelled at netflix between late 2018
and early 2019. in a march 2019 data
report business insider provided
analytics from jump shots that indicated
roughly 640 000 people watched the first
season of runaways in its first week on
hulu in november 2017 with 825 000
people tuning in to the second season
during its first week in december 2018.
that may sound like a lot of people but
it isn't even the bumped up viewership
number for marvel's runaway season 2 was
only about half the amount of people who
watched the least feud marvel show on
netflix the highly criticized iron fist
which pulled in 1.6 million viewers in
the first week after dropping its second
season unsurprisingly runaways couldn't
hold a candle to the most watched
netflix marvel show at the time
daredevil with 5.8 million week one
viewers for season two
no
that good huh
sunk the eight ball
well something went in business insider
noted that despite writing interest from
season one to season two of marvel's
runaways neither installment ever
reached a million viewer mark in the
first week this could be as the outlet
stated down to declining viewership for
all of marvel's streaming series
viewership trends that were headed in
the wrong direction for the superhero
series on netflix followed by the
rapid-fire cantillations of every single
marvel netflix show may have pushed more
casual viewers away from runaways
possibly because they feared the show
would soon suffer the same fate as
daredevil and the like additionally it
isn't as though runaways wasn't
interesting or exciting impressive
reviews and the loyal fan base proved
the opposite but the diverging
strategies that netflix and hulu
implemented with their respective marvel
properties may have been the downfall of
the combined collection of superhero
shows marvel's runaways included despite
the show's low ratings hulu still
renewed runaways for a third season
though it seems the streamer may have
ordered those final 10 episodes with the
knowledge that they'd be the last ones
people would ever watch on that note
it's been clear for quite some time now
that marvel television is experiencing
major shake-ups the creation of disney
streaming platform disney plus meant
that the mouse house which owns marvel
studios and his marvel television
division would be creating new original
series based on its gallery of
superheroes all to be produced by marvel
studios led by marvel entertainment
chief creative officer kevin feige
rather than marvel television headed up
by executive vice president jeff loeb in
an apparent effort to consolidate its
various properties and bring them to one
place marvel previously cleared house at
netflix by pulling the plug on daredevil
iron fist luke cage jessica jones and
the punisher with those shows done on
netflix fans would surely have to turn
elsewhere to get their superhero series
fix and where better to look than the
massive streamer that will be home to a
ton of marvel shows could marvel studios
executives have chatted with the tv
division and the folks at hulu about
bringing runaways to an end to further
clear the path for disney plus's marvel
universe to thrive it's not out of the
realm of reality and we're all that's
left
hey hey it's okay all right we're gonna
figure it out
we have each other
what also likely contributed to marvel's
runaways getting axed it's the fact that
jeff lobe was reportedly lined up to
leave marvel television the hollywood
reporter claims that loeb who has served
as the executive vp of marvel tv since
2010 will make a formal announcement of
his departure before the end of the
month at some point ahead of
thanksgiving day on thursday november
28th with runaways on its way out there
are only a handful of low produced
marvel series in existence agents of
shield which will end with its upcoming
seventh season hulu's horror themed
marvel show hellstrom and four
adult-oriented animated series it seems
evident that marvel studios is taking
over the television side of things from
well the actual television division of
the company marvel's runaways isn't the
only show to have become a casualty amid
all this change and it sadly may not be
the last he is hoping that what marvel
studios has planned with its disney plus
series will be worth all the hard take
of watching so many shows get snapped
away and that the few remaining marvel
tv-backed projects live to see at least
a few seasons
futurama is occult hit now but the first
time around the second show from the
creator of the simpsons was never given
a real shot to shine matt groening
became a true force in television
animation after creating the simpsons
which has aired an astonishing 600 plus
episodes on fox since premiering 30
years ago in 1989. in the late 90s with
the simpsons having become a cultural
phenomena fox began to express interest
in a new show from graining he came back
to fox with the show that would
eventually become futurama shut up and
take my money it should have been a
surefire hit instead though grening says
that fox seemingly never really wanted
futurama to succeed and even sabotage
their own show rather than let grining
have another hit during an interview
with mother jones grening had some not
so great things to say about working
with fox execs in hollywood you can't
believe what babies people are it's
really like being in junior high school
braining even said that fox executives
weren't fans of the simpsons either
revealing you can't expect people to
behave in their own best interest it's
in fox's best interest for this show to
be a success but they'd rather mess with
the show and have them fail then allow
creators independence and let them
succeed they don't like the simpsons at
fox so how did this affect futurama the
network moved the show around from time
slot to time slot then let it die a
quiet death in 2003 before it was
eventually revived by comedy central a
few years later but the network seemed
to be working against the show even
before it debuted when futurama was
originally coming down the pike grayning
wanted futurama to air at 8 30 pm on
sundays directly after the simpsons and
ahead of the x-files in order to give
the show the best chance to find a large
audience this seemed like a no-brainer
but fox disagreed for whatever reason
choosing instead to show only two
episodes of futurama in the sunday night
lineup before moving the series to a
much less desirable tuesday night time
slot by the time the second season of
futurama came around fox moved the show
back to the 8 30 pm sunday spot in which
the first two episodes aired then in a
move that alienated audiences further
fox shifted the show again in the middle
of the season this time bumping it up to
seven o'clock p.m on sunday and a
regularly timed sporting events which
were a huge moneymaker for fox made it
even harder to anticipate when futurama
would air each week this up and down
scheduling had another disappointing
consequence fox held on to episodes of
futurama made for the third and fourth
seasons and reserved them for a fifth
season that didn't even end up airing on
the network fox never formally canceled
futurama not in the way that television
series are usually acts nowadays the
network simply stopped purchasing new
episodes of futurama and the series went
out of production ahead of the fall 2003
broadcast season at least i still have
my self-respect
a couple years later though comedy
central picked up futurama the series
lasted another three seasons on the
network before it ended in 2013 proving
graining right and fox wrong in a 2003
interview with the calgary sun braining
offered his candid thoughts on the
situation the people at fox didn't ever
support the show and it wasn't to their
taste and in my opinion they're out of
their minds but they don't like the
simpsons either the idea of a tv show
that they haven't gotten their greasy
fingers all over creatively drives them
nuts that's why almost everything else
is so lousy we won the emmy for best
animated show and i didn't even get a
begrudging phone call from anyone at fox
that's a dark company that they can't
even make a fake phone call ouch tell
them how you really feel matt bite my
colossal metal ass ultimately though
granny got the last laugh futurama
became a cult classic hit on a different
network the simpsons continues to run to
this day and his show at netflix
disenchantment scored a second and third
season in late 2018
you know what they say living well is
the best revenge
here are the stories of some of the most
popular shows about cool teenagers that
aired in the 1990s and the reasons they
had to grow up move on and leave the
airwaves
good morning miss bliss a short-lived
disney channel vehicle for former child
star haley mills about an indiana
teacher was revamped by nbc into saved
by the bell a show about super cool
bayside california teen zack morris
the fourth wall breaking ferris
bueller-like character was supported in
his schemes by his inner circle mega
nerd screech jock ac slater fashionista
lisa turtle overachiever jesse spano and
sometimes girlfriend kelly kapowski they
also had a band called the zack attack
and hung out in a diner called the max
run by a magician saved by the bell was
kind of weird but it was a smash hit on
nbc's saturday morning schedule from
1989 to 1993.
so why did it have to end i'm sorry zach
i wish there was a way we could still
put on the show so you could be in it
the characters on the show aged in real
time and four years is as long as high
school lasts
not only were they scheduled to move on
from bayside high but tiffany thiessen
and elizabeth berkeley left the show
midway through the
1992-1993 season
nbc wasn't ready to say goodbye so it
launched the prime time continuation
saved by the bell the college years
which found zack out of his element as a
freshman at california university along
with most of his high school friends
viewers apparently weren't interested in
a non-bayside high bell and the show
bombed ranking at number 88 in the
ratings for the 1993-94 season which was
its only season
undaunted the studio launched yet
another spin-off saved by the bell the
new class which actually ended up
outlasting every other iteration of the
show during its seven season run
proving your high school years are
always a part of you members of the
original cast reunited for a saved by
the bell revival in 2020 streaming on
nbc's peacock platform
beverly hills 90210 was arguably the
starting point and inspiration for all
90s teen culture
not long after its premiere on fox in
1990 the soap became the hottest show on
the air for millions of young americans
fans needed to know what happened in the
social eyes of brandon and brenda walsh
minnesota transplants who moved to a
certain ritzy los angeles suburb along
with their various friends and romantic
partners
brenda's relationship with dylan became
iconic for millions of teens who bought
magazines and posters featuring the
show's photogenic cast
beverly hills 90210 proved so popular
and vital to the rise and continued
success of fox that the network kept it
on the air
it evolved from a high school show to a
college show then simply won about the
lives of young adults
by the year 2000 10 years after its
debut 90210 was the longest running
drama on american nighttime tv although
much of the original cast had long since
left and been replaced by new similarly
good-looking people
with the show long in the tooth and its
characters nearing their 30s fox
cancelled the once mighty teen soap
after nearly 300 episodes
like many long running series beverly
hills 90210 spawned a series of
spin-offs the most popular of which
melrose place became one of the defining
shows of its era in its own right
that tradition continued in 2008 with
90210 a spin-off that focused on the
lives of a different group of teens in
the ritzy area code after that show left
the air in 2013 yet another series bh
90210 reunited the original cast in 2019
this time with the actors playing
fictionalized versions of themselves
it's an appealingly weird idea but
viewers weren't interested bh90210 left
the airwaves after only six episodes now
we get to sit around and wait and see if
we get picked up oh that's a formality
right i mean it's the reboot of 90210 no
brainer
at the peak of beverly hills 90210
success came my so-called life an
extremely low-key drama about a girl
right in the middle of the social change
struggling with adolescence and her
parents expectations and perceptions of
her stories told with copious narration
from 15 year old claire danes who
starred as quiet introspective angela
chase
i've been kissed three times
no four times
no
three times
the show became a cult hit and critical
darling praised for its sensitive
non-condescending and realistic
portrayal of teenage life and danes
became one of the youngest performers to
ever be nominated in a lead acting
category at the emmy awards
however my so-called life was not even
remotely a hit ranking as the 116th most
watched show of the 1994 1994-1995 tv
season and the least watched program on
abc overall
that's probably because the network
scheduled it thursdays at 8 against
nbc's juggernaut must-see tv sitcom
lineup my so-called life went head to
head with matt about you and a brand new
sitcom called friends which would become
iconic for the generation at whom my
so-called life was directed
after one season abc canceled its
groundbreaking teen drama
when clarissa explains it all hit
nickelodeon in 1991 it was like nothing
else on tv at the time melissa joan hart
starred as adolescent clarissa darling
who talked to the audience to explain
her life the actions of others and any
other number of quirks of the human
existence
clarissa became a role model for her
creative flair abundant confidence and
wacky sense of humor
plus viewers could relate to the trials
of having goofy parents and an annoying
little brother
during clarissa explains it all's fourth
season nickelodeon decided that it
wasn't going to order more episodes why
at 17 the character of clarissa was too
old to be starring in a nickelodeon show
but not cool enough to star in a show on
sibling network mtv
creator mitchell kriegman told mental
floss in those days nickelodeon stopped
at 14 and mtv started at 15 or 16 and
there was no middle ground they didn't
cross that line because that was mtv
territory and the attitude of mtv was
way different than the attitude of
nickelodeon kriegman attempted to skip
the demographic pigeonholing altogether
and in 1995 pitched to cbs a
continuation called clarissa in which
the college age title character lands an
internship at a new york newspaper it
never became a series
the early fox network took some chances
airing shows far edgier and more unusual
than the stuff seen on the other major
broadcast networks
in 1990 it aired the surreal high school
comedy parker lewis can't lose later
shortened to just parker lewis the show
starred corn and nemik as an extremely
cool teen doing constant battle with his
principal with the help of his friends a
rocker named mikey and a nerd named
jerry whose trench coat pockets held a
treasury of bizarre gadgets
shot in the film-like single camera
format when studio audiences and laugh
tracks were the norm parker lewis's
quick cuts weird camera angles and
special effects certainly put it ahead
of its time after three seasons both
show and network were changing rapidly
co-creator clyde phillips told the
hollywood reporter the danger when you
do a high school show is that your
characters have to grow and in fact they
have to grow out of high school
as for fox the network was quote looking
a bit to get more adult co-creator lon
diamond said explaining that the network
was at the time aiming for more serious
teen content fox pulled the plug in 1993
after three seasons
teenage singer brandi was everywhere in
the mid 90s releasing a slew of r b
tinged pop smashes like i wanna be down
baby and the boy is mine in 1996 upn
capitalized on brandy's high status with
teenagers and gave her a sitcom signing
her to star on moisha as moisha a los
angeles teen going through the normal
trials and tribulations of american
adolescent life
at a big event in new york's madison
square garden in may 2001 upn announced
its big moves for its slate of
programming set to debut the following
fall
it was nothing short of an overhaul what
with the cancellations of its two
longest running shows star trek voyager
which had been on the air since 1995 and
militia ending its five-year run
the reason
moisia had quote run its course
according to ceo dean valentine who said
it was time to freshen up the night
getting rid of militia may have also
been a way to make room and set aside
some cash
during the same media con fab where the
show was officially cancelled upn
announced that it had acquired two
series from rival mini network the wb
roswell and buffy the vampire slayer
most movies and teen shows about teens
are about the rich and popular kids
mtv's animated hit daria had plenty of
those characters except that they were a
source of derision for the heroes
brutally sarcastic and proud social
pariah daria morgendorffer and her best
friend aspiring painter jane the series
brutally mocked high school and all its
social conventions with darya delivering
her vicious and pointed criticisms at
the jocks cheerleaders and her
popularity obsessed sister quinn you
can't go you'll ruin everything
you know
i really should broaden my social
horizons daria which debuted in 1997 as
a spin-off of mtv's beavis and butthead
came about when the network needed a
show to attract female audiences
showrunner glenn eichler was left mostly
to his own devices and mtv offered him
and his team full creative freedom to
make the show they wanted that also
meant he got to end it on his own terms
when he was ready and he wrapped up
after five seasons with a tv movie about
daria's graduation
but there's a good chance daria wouldn't
have made it to another season even if
eichler had wanted to do that he told
variety not too long after the series
ended mtv animation imploded so i don't
know if we would have even made it to a
sixth year ryan murphy has created a lot
of shows in addition to provocative
stuff for grown-ups like nip tuck pose
and american horror story he's probably
best known for getting glee on the air
but he honed his teen tv chops with his
first ever series the darkly comic high
school so popular which hit the wb in
1999. it was about two very different
teenagers cheerleader brooke and school
newspaper editor sam forced into
togetherness when their respective
single parents marry popular seemingly
fit right in with the wb's late 90s
lineup of teen fare like dawson's creek
and roswell but murphy later claimed
that there was a disconnect between his
progressive vision for the show and what
the network wanted it to be he told
entertainment weekly
they never got me and they kept trying
to turn me into something else they
would give me notes like the mary cherry
character like could she be less gay
even though i'm depressed and feel life
has no meaning since that editorial
this restroom always makes me feel so
pretty overall he quote didn't have a
good experience making popular despite
his following the network's every
suggestion the show still got cancelled
after two years anyway
the hit 1995 movie clueless concerned a
close-obsessed beverly hills teen named
cher horowitz who just wants to get her
driver's license hang out with her
friend dion and give new student tai a
life-changing makeover the cheery and
casual dynamic along with the film's
popularity made a tv version almost a
foregone conclusion and clueless the
show wound up on abc's tgif lineup in
the fall of 1996.
several cast members of the film
reprised their roles while rachel
blanchard took over for alicia
silverstone as the lead despite
moderately high ratings it ranked number
53 for the year abc canceled it only for
the teen skewing upn to seize it
the change in venue to the generally
little watch smaller network hurt the
show viewership fell and after the third
season of clueless saw another ratings
drop upn canceled the show
buffy a vampire slayer played by sarah
michelle gellar constantly faced danger
violence and death in the line of duty
and buffy the vampire slayer of the show
outlasted almost as many threats it
survived a rescinded cancellation the
second death of the title character a
network switch from the wb to upn the
exit of popular characters angel and
cordelia to the spin-off angel and
consistently poor ratings never ranking
higher than 120th place in the annual
nielsen tally
nevertheless buffy's crew produced 144
episodes of what would become one of the
biggest cult shows of all time chock
full of action stunts and serious acting
that amounted to a tremendous grind for
geller and by 2003 she'd had enough i
quit
i resign i'm fired
she told entertainment weekly i'm 26 i'm
married i never see my husband you want
to pick up and go try other things live
in different places
it feels right and you have to listen to
that
without buffy there could be no buffy
and so upn wrapped up the series
sci-fi shows that didn't live up to
expectations were often unceremoniously
canceled in the 90s usually for
complicated fascinating and bizarre
reasons here's why some sci-fi classics
near classics and never got to be
classics had their runs cut short
even today the concept of quantum leap
is pretty novel offering up endless
possibilities for a sci-fi show dr sam
beckett develops time travel technology
and tests it on himself traveling into
the past and temporarily appearing as a
different person in each episode
after some humorous growing pains as sam
gets used to his new identity he
ultimately rolls with it and invariably
leaves his momentary host's life a
little bit better than before he arrived
and his guide through it all is a
present-day-based hologram version of
his friend al not only one of the few
network sci-fi shows at the time the
1989-1993 series was the rare genre show
to receive attention from mainstream
awards bodies quantum leap earned three
emmy nominations for outstanding drama
series while star scott bakula and dean
stockwell both won a golden globe but in
spite of the acclaim quantum leap never
leapt to the top of the tv ratings chart
nbc frequently bounced it around
multiple time slots during its four year
run making it hard for fans to find
viewership numbers reflected that as the
series never ranked higher than number
53 in the annual ratings in 1993 nbc
cancelled quantum leap and sam never
even made it home
it's only recently that superhero based
series have become mainstream
entertainment worthy of huge budgets and
good time slots in fall 2019 half the
cw's 12 prime time shows were based on
dc comics characters one that's been
consistently popular since its debut is
the flash which stars grant gustin as
barry allen aka the title character who
wears a red jumpsuit and can run
preposterously fast however it's
actually the second network primetime
show about the speedster following cbs's
1990 series the flash starring john
wesley's ship as the world's quickest
hero a dark moody crime heavy show cbs
had a lot of faith in the series
dropping a whopping 6 million bucks on
the pilot episode alone including 100
000 on ship's flash costume
so
what am i wearing here
cbs didn't play it safe with the
scheduling though placing the flash a 60
minute show in a bizarre hour straddling
time slot of 8 30 to 9 30 p.m opposite
nbc's mega hits a different world in
cheers as well as fox's hot soap beverly
hills 90210 too few people watched such
an expensive show and cbs stopped it
after its one and only season
the early 90s nbc series sequest dsv had
all the makings of a hit after all the
show was set on a high-tech deep sea
vessel staffed by genius scientists
portrayed by the likes of jaws star roy
scheider and teen heartthrob of the
moment jonathan brandis as they had
exciting action-packed sci-fi adventures
the crew also interacted with a talking
dolphin named darwin and met a mermaid a
joint production of universal studios in
steven spielberg's amblin television it
boasted a huge per episode budget that
made for great for tv at the time
special effects and yet nbc couldn't
pull in a big audience for its freshman
season seaquest dsv ranked a lowly
number 83 in the ratings perhaps because
it aired opposite cbs's very popular
murder she wrote and fox's martin
efforts to revamp the series switching
out cast members committing to less
science-heavy stories and venturing
outside of the submarine more often only
worked a little with the show moving up
to 64th place in the ratings for the
1994-1995 season for season three
producers once more made broad changes
moving the action ahead 10 years dumping
schneider in favor of michael ironside
as a new captain and renaming the show
seaquest 2032 that didn't do the trick
as the show fell to a lowly number 117
before nbc permanently sank the series
anchoring nickelodeon's saturday night
snick lineup for most of the mid 90s the
secret world of alex mack was a sci-fi
show about an arizona teenager who gets
covered in a secret proprietary chemical
that gives her powers like telekinesis
the ability to shoot electricity out of
her fingertips and to transform into a
sentient puddle at will one minute i'm
walking home the next there's a crash
and i'm drenched in some weird chemical
the powers were difficult to control and
often arbitrary making the secret world
of alex mack a sci-fi allegory about the
constantly baffling weirdness of
adolescence alex mack ran on nickelodeon
from 1994 to 1998 and the network was
more than willing to green light a fifth
season executive producer and co-creator
tommy lynch took star larissa olenek
along with her mother and manager out to
a fancy dinner at a hollywood restaurant
there he formally presented his offer
for season five which also included a
substantial amount of money and a
proposal of an alex maca movie however
olenek said no thanks the actress told
huffpost it was an incredible thing he
was offering me and i knew that at the
time but i was a little burnout she
wanted to finish high school and attend
college and also leave the alex mac
character where she was at with the
conclusion of season four as elenic
explained she was starting to grow up in
that last season she gets a boyfriend i
just kind of wanted to keep it innocent
babylon 5 was among the most prominent
sci-fi shows of the 90s its first four
seasons aired on local tv stations
affiliated with the prime primetime
entertainment network programming block
and when that conglomeration went
defunct the show finished its run on
cable network tnt babylon 5 ran for five
seasons as had been the intent from the
beginning for creator j michael
strzinski he'd mapped out one big grand
story about a space station its
inhabitants and the sometimes warring
alien races it encounters in 1999 about
a year and a half after the final
babylon 5 aired tnt broadcast a call to
arms a babylon 5 made for tv movie that
acted as a bridge and set up to a new
space set series called crusade an
entire first season of 13 episodes were
written shot and completed only for tnt
to preemptively cancel crusade before
its premiere rendering the whole thing a
limited series according to strzinski
tnt wanted the show to appeal to a
broader audience and the studio made him
comply with its creative demands
ultimately strazinski didn't give the
network what it wanted so it pulled the
plug
superboy got off to a rocky start
debuting in syndication in 1988 the show
followed superman aka clark kent just
before he'd grow into his powers as the
man of steel and find work as a
journalist at the daily planet john
haynes newton won the role of
college-age superman but he was fired
after season one when he asked for more
money could it be because you always
have your greedy paws where they don't
belong
that also happened to be around the same
time he arguably violated a morals
clause in his contract with a public
drunkenness arrest producer ilya salkind
replaced him with a 31 year old
baby-faced
gerard christopher who proved a good fit
the ratings for the newly rebranded the
adventures of superboy flew into the
list of the 10 most watched syndicated
tv series a few episodes after his
arrival the adventures of superboy ran
for 100 episodes over four seasons and
it was popular enough to keep going but
superman controlling studio warner
brothers wouldn't have it it started
work on a new superman tv series lois
and clark the new adventures of superman
set to air in prime time on network
television making it a much more high
profile project than the lowly
syndicated superboy warner not only
wouldn't renew the show but the studio
filed paperwork regarding saulkind's
right to make superman television
preventing even superboy reruns from
airing
in 1993 mighty morphin power rangers
debuted and it quickly became a
multimedia kitty phenomenon not seen
since the likes of masters of the
universe a decade earlier the plot
followed a group of teenagers who were
bestowed with mystical martial arts
abilities and the control of giant
robots which they used to fight space
monsters mighty morphin power rangers
dominated the ratings while action
figures of the different power rangers
flew off the shelves a year later the
children's television landscape was
flooded with blatant power rangers
clones including tattooed teenage alien
fighters from beverly hills superhuman
samurai cyber squad and vr troopers
trooper transform
in that series a group of friends are
given fighting suits and powerful
vehicles by the mysterious professor
heart who needs them to fight the
menacing army of grimlord which is
attempting to break out of the virtual
reality world and into the meat space
unlike the power rangers the vr troopers
weren't teens but well into their 20s
and unlike the other power rangers
clones vr troopers lasted two seasons as
opposed to one what ultimately did it in
was that it couldn't compete with power
rangers where it really counted toy
sales the whole point of vr troopers was
to move toys and not enough kids bought
the merchandise to justify a third
season of the tv show
if you were a kid tween or non-partying
adult in the early 90s the place to be
on friday nights was in front of the tv
tuned in to abc's tgif lineup of sappy
family-friendly programming like full
house family matters and step by step by
1996 many tgif shows were fading and abc
made attempts to lure in newer and even
younger viewers with puppet-based
programming and during that season
muppets tonight and aliens in the family
joined tgif the first was an update of
the classic the muppet show while the
latter was a bizarre sci-fi sitcom about
a brady bunch-esque blended family
except dad doug brody and his kids were
human and mom cookie and her offspring
were mildly monstrous aliens their meat
cute cookie abducted doug and then he
fell in love with her the show's real
star was the strange and grotesque bobot
a talking baby genius with a taste for
chaos and destruction the creature even
had a catchphrase
i require putting pudding in the morning
well sally doesn't think that's a very
good idea
although the aliens were the work of the
famous jim henson's creature shop the
tonally dissonant aliens in the family
didn't mesh with the rest of tgif and it
lasted just eight episodes nor did it
help to revamp the tgif lineup which by
fall 1996 was back to its lineup of teen
centered shows
star trek the next generation revived
and reinvented the star trek franchise
on the small screen leaving behind the
original series this campy vibe and
clunky effects in favor of sleek high
production values but it also ramped up
the thoughtful meaningful allegorical
plots all led by the captivating patrick
stewart as the kind and brave captain
jean-luc picard after seven successful
seasons the next generation wrapped up
with a finale episode that drew more
than 31 million viewers blockbuster
ratings for a network tv show but
unheard of for a series syndicated to
individual local stations a few months
later the show received an emmy
nomination for outstanding drama series
which was an extreme rarity for a
non-network show and a sci-fi series so
why would paramount set phasers to
cancel the big screen beckon just four
days after the last episode of the next
generation wrapped cast members reported
to a different stage on the paramount
lot to film star trek generations the
first movie in the long-running
blockbuster franchise to feature the
casts of both flagship star trek shows
in that film the old crew passed the
torch to the newer one william shatner's
captain kirk died making room for picard
and company to occupy three more star
trek movies
with the commercial and critical
popularity of star trek the next
generation it was clear that 90s tv
viewers wanted more science fiction
options particularly star trek shows in
1993 the space station set star trek
deep space nine debuted in syndication
featuring avery brooks as commanding
officer benjamin cisco the first
african-american lead character in
franchise history i can assure you this
old cat may not be as toothless as you
think
right now i've got 5 000 photon
torpedoes armed and ready to launch
ds9 earns solid ratings and syndication
for most of its early seasons
guaranteeing at least a moderately long
run the success of fox in the late 80s
and early 90s showed the tv industry
that there was room on the dial beyond
the big three of abc cbs and nbc in 1993
plans for new channels upn and wb were
underway the new networks competed to
nail down affiliates most of which were
formerly independent channels around the
us and which had relied heavily on
syndicated programming like deep space
nine in short order a few hundred
formerly independent stations signed up
to air upn and wb programming and
non-network shows suddenly had less
access to air time oddly enough upn was
operated by paramount the rights holder
of star trek properties the very first
show ever broadcast on upn voyager
another star trek series don't let them
do anything
that takes you off the bridge of that
ship because while you're there
you can make a difference
2020 has been a year of bad news and
things aren't much different in the
world of television sadly a number of
much-loved tv series have come to an end
this year here's the real reason these
tv shows were canceled in 2020
the reality police show cops began all
the way back in march 1989 and continued
airing new episodes for 30 years this is
despite the show being cancelled by its
original network home box in may 2013
before getting a second lease on life at
spike tv which later became the
paramount network after spike picked up
the series studio president kevin k told
the hollywood reporter cops is a
remarkable series that has been able to
sustain strong ratings well into its
third decade a monumental achievement in
television but this remarkable series
wouldn't last forever and in june 2020
the paramount network made the
announcement that cops had finally
reached the end of the line the show's
abrupt ending came in the wake of
worldwide protests against race-based
police brutality a matter that many
critics have long accused cops of
minimizing according to the new york
times in 2013 civil rights group color
of change proclaimed the show's
producers have built a profit model
around distorted and dehumanizing
portrayals of black americans and the
criminal justice system in the wake of
2020's protest over police brutality
these complaints found a renewed sense
of impact and likely influenced the
show's cancellation this wasn't the only
reason cops ended though for example
cop's future wasn't helped by the fact
that according to deadline paramount
network has been moving away from all
unscripted programming in october 2020
vulture reported that cops was briefly
resuming production but only quote to
fulfill commitments to overseas
territories these episodes won't air in
the u.s
arrow was to the arrowverse what iron
man was to the marvel cinematic universe
a barrage of superhero shows spun off
from this green arrow tv show which
kicked off its run on october 2012 but
everything ends eventually and so it was
with aero which aired its final episode
on january 28th 2020. the news of
arrow's final season was announced via a
tweet by the show's lead actor stephen
amell who tweeted playing oliver queen
has been the greatest professional
experience of my life but you can't be a
vigilante forever arrow will return for
a final run of 10 episodes this fall
there's so much to say for now i just
want to say thank you amel later
expanded on his thoughts on leaving the
show revealing that he was the primary
impetus for the show's end and that he
had originally hoped arrow could go on
without him the iconography of green
arrow has always been something that's
bigger than
than me or any other actor that's
playing him or voicing him like iron man
arrow is now gone from the universe he
began but the show's legacy will
doubtless live on
when it debuted on abc in february 2015
the sitcom fresh off the boat was the
first network primetime show to feature
an asian american family in 20 years as
eddie wong whose memoir of the series
was based on said to over 1 000 guests
that fresh off the boat's premiere party
today we've arrived starring randall
park and constance wu the landmark
program would go on to run for six
seasons after exceeding 100 episodes abc
announced that fresh off the boat would
be pulling into port for good once its
sixth season wrapped up in february
2020. in a statement regarding the
show's cancellation abc president kerry
burke said we couldn't be prouder of
this game-changing show and the impact
it has had on our cultural landscape
burke didn't give a specific reason for
the show's cancellation however variety
later noted the series had seen its
radiance decline as it went on and was
moved to friday nights for its fifth
season diminishing ratings would easily
explain the show's cancellation as would
the increasingly busy schedules of its
lead actors nevertheless a powerful
legacy of fresh off the boat is certain
to keep on resonating for years to come
in june 2019 the good place creator
michael sher dropped a bombshell about
his beloved nbc comedy the show would be
wrapping up after its fourth season
where many of the cancellations in 2020
happened at the whims of network
executives the good place ended exactly
when its creator wanted it to sure
explained after the good place was
picked up for season 2 the writing staff
and i began to map out as best we could
the trajectory of the show given the
ideas we wanted to explore and the pace
at which we wanted to present those
ideas i began to feel like four seasons
just over 50 episodes was the right
lifespan this aligned with prior
comments sure made about the temporary
nature of the good place in particular
sure mentioned to the hollywood reporter
in december 2018 this is not a show
that's destined to be on for nine years
it's not a 200 episode friends kind of
deal it's not a hangout show it's
understandable if good place fans wanted
the show to go on forever after all
nobody wants to see their favorite show
come to an end but those fans can at
least rest assured that sure and his
team were satisfied with the final
series and that the good place got to
end on its own forking terms take it
sleazy the original penny dreadful which
also ended before its time in 2016
received widespread critical acclaim the
first season's rotten tomatoes consensus
declared that skillfully shot and
superbly acted penny dreadful is
perplexing in a good way even if it's a
bit silly at times more than that the
original series also established its own
dedicated fan pace so given how widely
liked the program was it was inevitable
that a spin-off would continue the penny
dreadful saga enter penny dreadful city
of angels which took the franchise
across the pond to los angeles gave it a
fresh 1930 setting and featured a brand
new cast while the show's creator john
logan publicly teased details for a
second season of city of angels the
spin-off sadly wasn't made to last in a
statement the show's network showtime
said showtime has decided not to move
forward with another season of penny
dreadful city of angels we would like to
thank executive producers john logan
michael aguilar and the entire casting
crew for their outstanding work on this
project no reason was given for the
cancellation but speculation has
attributed it to low viewership
according to screen rant the series
premiere only brought in around 800 000
viewers and things only went downhill
from there by the finale only around 650
000 people were watching with numbers
like that it's probably no surprise that
city of angels was sent straight to tv
hell
in may 2019 deadline wrote netflix might
be rewriting the rule book with a
business model that have all shows off
and running for two to three seasons
sadly this practice has led to
criminally short runs for shows like
daredevil and altered carbon one
exception to this rule however is the
ashton kutcher sitcom the ranch the
half-hour comedy kicked off its run in
april 2016 and proceeded to go on for 8
seasons and 80 episodes before finally
wrapping up in january 2020 reporting on
the show's cancellation deadlines
suggested that the show had never been
expected to go beyond four seasons the
idea that the ranch would go on in its
own terms was reflected in comments by
its leading man who told wtf with marc
maron the story of the ranch was told i
love everything that we did netflix owns
the show so it's not like there was this
big syndication boom that was going to
come if we shot two more seasons and
although the ranch has been put out to
pasture it can at least hold its head
high since it managed to surpass fuller
house and claim the title netflix's
longest-running multi-camera comedy
in 2019 variety announced the empire has
fallen fox announced monday that music
drama empire's recently announced sixth
season will be the show's last the news
came as a shock for empire creator lee
daniels however who didn't expect the
show to end so soon he told the rap i
was surprised honestly i was told that
it was possible this could happen but it
has become realer and realer the closer
we get to the end and i am sad sad that
our show is done so just why did empire
crumble after six seasons fox gave no
official word on the matter but the
hollywood reporter noted that the show's
shift to being a disney owned show
likely played a part in the matter the
outlet also noted that jesse smallet's
ongoing legal affairs probably had an
impact on the show's premature end it
also can't be forgotten that empire
suffered a sharp drop in ratings over
the years going from 9.9 million viewers
for its season premiere to just 2.9
million viewers for the series finale
the reasons for empire's abrupt ending
were many though the drama surrounding
the show didn't end with its
cancellation unfortunately the 20
episode final season was cut down by two
episodes due to the covet 19 pandemic
this didn't just result in a shorter
season it meant that empire's intended
series finale was never filmed wrapping
the show's run on a very sour noted d
for a long time it appeared that
supernatural would never end having
kicked off in september 2005 the
fantastical exploits of sam and dean
winchester managed to go on for 15
seasons and a whopping 320 episodes and
sure the dynamic duo managed to conquer
a variety of other worldly beings in
that time span but even they couldn't
defeat the prospect of cancellation the
news that supernatural's 15th season
would be its last was announced via
jared padilecki's instagram account he
wrote dear espn family season 1 jensen
ackles and i want you to know that next
season season 15 will be the last season
of supernatural fellow lead actor jensen
ackel said the decision to end the show
was an intentional one explaining it was
months and months if not years of
discussion between he and i between the
rest of the cast between crew between
our writers between our producers
between the studio between the network
nobody wanted to see this show fizzle
out true to form supernatural's final
season has managed to go on much longer
than expected the series was originally
set to conclude in may 2020 but the
covet 19 pandemic shut down filming for
the final season the production was only
able to resume in august meaning that
the supernatural series finale won't air
until november 19 2020 five months later
than originally intended
netflix's first original animated
cartoon aimed at adults kicked off its
run in august 2014. initial reviews were
mixed but it wasn't long before bojack
horseman had become one of the most
critically acclaimed shows around oh no
the responsibilities are already
starting in particular bojack was lauded
for its inimitable mix of light-hearted
humor and heart-wrenching for rays into
addiction depression and the dark side
of hollywood the show's rotten tomato
consensus for season six reads
bittersweet and brilliant to the very
end bojack horseman's final season
manages to keep surprising viewers with
his empathy and depth solidifying its
place is one of tv's greatest offerings
and at long last bojack horseman came to
an end in january 2020. the conclusion
was not one imposed by the show's
creator raphael bob waxburg but rather
came from netflix which gave bob waxburg
advanced warning that the end was near
as he told andy wyer they don't have to
do that obviously but i said i would
appreciate it if i could have the
forewarning to give the show a proper
finale and not set up some cliffhangers
that will never pay off so when they
picked up season six they said hey
remember how you asked for that heads up
we think that this is your heads up
while bojack horseman may have come to
an end it at least went out on a genuine
high and cemented itself as one of the
funniest and most emotional shows of the
last decade really in the end isn't that
all you can ask for